Da sind wir wieder.
Schöne Grüße nach Toronto übrigens.
Ja, schöne Grüße nach Deutschland. Das ist ja, ihr seid ja so weit weg. Du bist so weit weg. Sechs Stunden Zeitunterschied. Ja, ja, ich bin weit weg, ich weiß.
Das hört man auch bei Skype. Ich dachte, da könnte man nur hin morsen bisher. Aber es geht offensichtlich auf Sprachübertragung.
Also ich finde, es ist nicht so flummen, wie ich dachte. Mal gucken, wie sich das so entwickelt, wie die Software nach zwei Stunden so irgendwie läuft. Ja, aber immerhin, so kann man dann auch nochmal einen Podcast machen. Das ist jetzt das erste Mal, dass wir hier einen sogenannten Double-Ender machen. Oder genau genommen ist es sogar ein Triple-Ender. Kennt ihr den Begriff?
Ja, hast du schonmal erzählt.
Aber da hat mich nicht zugehört. Insofern kannst du es mir nochmal erzählen.
Der Unterschied ist, man nimmt nicht ein gemeinsames Mix-Signal auf, wie wir das sonst machen. Sondern jeder nimmt sozusagen seinen Ender auf, lokal, damit es bessere Qualität hat. Und dann fügt man das nachträglich zusammen. Das ist eigentlich so eine gängige Methode. Es ist ein bisschen mehr Aufwand. Man hat den Vorteil, dass wir Skype nur benutzen, um uns zu synchronisieren. Aber am Ende sollte eigentlich eine ganz brauchbare Sprachqualität für die Zuhörer dabei rauskommen.
Ja, ich hoffe.
Und die Zuhörer sind ja das Wichtigste, stimmt's?
Ja, wir machen alles für unsere Zuhörer.
Ach so, Zuhörer, ach so, ok. Ja, ja, bestimmt, bestimmt.
So sieht's aus. Apropos Zuhörer, apropos Zuhörer.
Ich war neulich auf einer Party und bin begrüßt worden von Leuten, die ich vorher noch mal nicht kannte und deren Namen ich mir dummerweise auch nicht gemerkt habe. Trotzdem Grüße mit den Worten. Max 3, 40 sind zu lang. Ich glaub, das war ne Botschaft.
Ja, das kann schon sein. Aber es gibt auch die anderen Leute, denen kann es nicht lang genug sein. Aber ich denke heute können wir mal für die anderen was machen, weil so viel Zeit hab ich leider nicht. Wir sind hier ganz schön unterdankt.
Aber ich will auch noch einen Hörer grüßen. Und zwar den Hörer, der mir irgendwie 10.0, 10.1, 10.2 und ich glaub sogar 10.4 als Original-DVDs geschickt hat. Möcht ich mich herzlich bedanken.
Ach echt?
Ja, hab ich bekommen.
Der Aufruf hat sozusagen Früchte getragen.
Hat Früchte getragen, ja. Mir fehlt jetzt nur noch ein 10.3.
Echt? Okay, wer also noch ein 10.3 Original-DVD rumliegen hat?
Und zwar nicht das, was dabei liegt, sondern die generischen Installer, die man kaufen musste. Weil die laufen nämlich aus allen Plattformen. Genau. Weil die dabei liegen, sind immer so ein bisschen aufs System festgenagelt.
Gibt es bei denn auf einem aktuellen MacBook noch irgendwie so ein 10.0 zu laufen? Mit PeerPC oder irgendwie sowas? Gibt es da eine Möglichkeit?
PeerPC kenn ich nicht und ich glaub auch nicht.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ah, okay.
Also weder kann ich mir vorstellen, dass man das wirklich will, noch glaub ich, dass es technisch funktioniert.
Aber ich hab letztens mal deine Rapsody-Discetten gebootet. Und die booten noch, aber beim Installieren kam dann Colonel Panic. Aber so theoretisch geht noch alles.
Nachdem sie irgendwie die Überbleibsel der Atomexplosionen runtergekratzt haben, wenn sie dann die alten Rechner ausgraben, dann können sie ja vielleicht auch noch die Disketten installieren. Aber wir reden mal doch lieber über die Neuigkeiten. Jetzt haben wir drei Wochen verbaselt. Letzte Woche hat es halt irgendwie nicht geklappt. Jetzt bin ich auch mit der Zeit ein bisschen knapp, weil, wie vielleicht so einige wissen, sind wir jetzt hier gerade in Toronto und sind jetzt im Endspurt mit unserem neuen Blinkenlites-Projekt. Nächste Woche.
Und schafft das?
Naja, also wir kämpfen gerade wirklich. Es ist wirklich ein Stück harter Arbeit und man muss so viele Probleme gleichzeitig bekämpfen. Ich hatte das schon wieder vergessen, wie knifflig das alles war. Aber mal gucken. Bisher hatten wir immer Glück gehabt und toi toi toi, kann ich nur sagen.
Wir spielen jetzt gerade wie blöd an seinem Mikrofon rum.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich hab gerade eben mal kurz ein bisschen an meinem Mikrofon rumgespielt, Entschuldigung.
Wir machen ja übrigens hier so ein Skype-Conference-Call. Wir machen hier ein Skype-Conference-Call für unsere Zuhörer, damit die wissen, was wir hier schon wieder für Technik einsetzen.
Skype, oh mein Gott! Was kommt als nächstes?
Skype ist gut.
Google Docs?
Ich hätte ja iChat benutzt, aber egal.
Was ich an Skype wirklich, ja, das Problem mit iChat ist, das funktioniert nicht immer. Und Skype funktioniert eigentlich immer. Na ja, weiß ich nicht. Klar, wir haben auch mal die Erfahrung gehabt, dass es mal nicht ging, aber ich kenne keine Software, die so zuverlässig durch Nuts und komische Firewall-Konfigurationen durchgeht, während ich mit iChat nicht mehr in der Lage bin, Dateien zu übertragen. Zuverlässig über Java. Und das geht bei Skype einfach immer. Immer, immer, immer.
Dieses Dateiübertragungsthema ist sowieso eine lustige Sache. Es gibt ja gerade bei iChat, dass man Video-Chat am Laufen hat und trotzdem keine Dateien übertragen kann. Das finde ich höchst absurd.
Ja, das ist total bekloppt. Ich meine, ich weiß auch nicht so richtig, was da eigentlich die Gründe sind. Ach, was weiß ich. Ich glaube, die setzen da einfach auf die falschen Protokolle. Das haben wir schon mal angeschnitten. Das will ich jetzt nicht wieder aufreißen, das Thema, da bin ich jetzt auch nicht vorbereitet. Aber dieser ganze S-Ton-Quatsch und diese ganze Methodiken, über NAT rauszukommen mit externen Servern, die man dazu braucht, die einem dann so von außen signalisieren, was die IP-Adressen von außen sind und dann eben sozusagen die Kommunikation zwischen Clients machen, die beide hinter NAT sind. Das funktioniert halt in manchen Fällen und in manchen Fällen funktioniert es dann eben nicht, weil unterschiedliche Router, unterschiedliche Arten und Weisenhaken mit NAT umzugehen und mit unterschiedliches Port-Mapping nach außen haben und das führt eben zu diesen ganzen Problemen. Und das ist halt, meiner Erfahrung nach, bei iChat einfach ein großes Problem. Ich kriege dann 90% der Fälle keine Dateien übertragen.
Aber das klappt mit Alium auch nie.
Mit Alium ist es noch schlimmer. Ja, es gibt neue, wa? Langweiliger ging es ja gar nicht mehr. Es werden wirklich alles schon vorher vorausgesagt worden.
Nein, nicht der Genius-Button.
Doch, auch gerade der.
Ernsthaft? Ja, das hab ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Mensch, ist das schon lange her. Da hat dieser Dick-Typ, Kevin Rose, ein schönes Bild gemalt, wie das alles aussehen würde. Und exakt so sah es dann auch aus. Ich erinnere mich. Liebe Hörer, so lang ist das schon her.
Er meinte ja, er würde nie wieder sowas machen. Wenn er demnächst wieder einen Tipp kippt, dann wird er ihn nicht mehr bekannt geben, weil er von allen Leuten, wie ich finde, total zurechtgestutzt wurde, dass sie eben sozusagen die Überraschung versaut haben. In letzter Zeit, finde ich, hält Apple eh nicht mehr so richtig dicht. Also so, wann könnt ihr euch erinnern, wann gab es das letzte Mal eine richtige Überraschung, das war das iPhone.
Dass es kommt, war auch aber klar eigentlich.
Nö, das war nicht klar.
Na ja, doch, es war schon, es ging schon.
Es hat sich verdichtet und es hatte sich auch schon vorher immer häufig verdichtet, wo man hätte sagen können, jetzt kommt's. Und so richtig vorhergesagt hat's keiner. Und die paar Vorhersagen, insbesondere von diesem komischen Kevin Rose, die waren alle falsch.
Auf jeden Fall waren sie nicht sonderlich präzise. Das stimmt.
Naja, die werden schon mal wieder...
Jetzt weiß man schon, MacBook Pro kommt irgendwie und es wird irgendwie Alu sein und ein bisschen schwarz haben, ein bisschen runder sein und bababa. Und es wird wahrscheinlich nur ein Firewire 800 Port haben und all das klingt irgendwie schon wieder so scheiße-saumäßig glaubwürdig, dass der ganze Spaß schon wieder weg ist. Ich will meine eigene alte geheimnis-cremerische Apple-Gerüchteküche irgendwie wieder haben.
Die, wo nichts gestimmt hat.
Wo sie alle daneben lagen, genau. Ja, aber was ist denn nun gekommen? Also es gab eine Überraschung für mich, eine angenehme, dass sie nämlich dem iPod einen Mikrofoneingang spendiert haben.
Genau. Und er hat Tasten zum lauter Leisermachen. Also dem iPod Touch jetzt, ne?
Der vorher hatte die Tasten nicht.
Der vorher hatte die Tasten nicht. Das ist jetzt neu. Vor allem bei Spielen ein Problem.
Das ist wirklich ein echtes Argument. Für mich war ja lange Zeit auch ein Grund, nicht aufs iPhone zu wechseln, dass diese ganze Steuerung mit dem Rad, die ich so gewohnt bin, da hatte ich ja letztes Mal schon darüber erzählt, dass es irgendwie weg ist. Lautstärke ist einfach etwas, da muss man einfach immer ran. Und dass das am Gerät ist, das ist schon mal wirklich ein Fortschritt. Das muss man halt auch blind benutzen können. Das iPod Touch nicht hatte, war wieder ein totaler Rückschritt. Genau, das muss man blind benutzen können. Insofern sag ich nur hurra mit diesem neuen Headset, was sie jetzt rausbringen, was ja nicht nur das Mikrofon hat, sondern eben auch lauter und leiser, plus diesen Single, Double, Triple-Click-Button.
Den hat ja der Kopfhörer, der beim iPhone dabei ist, auch, oder? Die Funktionalität? Sicher?
Ne, ne, ne. Das ist jetzt nämlich die Frage. Funktioniert das neue Headset? Funktioniert das auch am iPhone? Meines Wissens nach nämlich nicht.
Dazu haben sie sich bisher nicht geäußert. Und meine Vermutung ist, das Ding kommt ja jetzt erst im Laufe des Oktober oder November raus. In dem Laufe des Oktober soll es rauskommen.
Da gibt es ja eine neue Software, richtig?
Die 2.2 für das iPhone? Mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn irgendwie so ein 2.1.1 oder 2.2, was auch immer, Update kommt, wo sie das dann mit unterstützen. Weil das kann eigentlich nur eine Softwareänderung sein. Weil es ist ja nicht so, dass sie dafür noch mal einen extra Pin haben.
Das war auch meine Hoffnung. Aber ich glaube, den Kopfhörer gibt es schon. Es gibt ihn bloß noch nicht als In-Ear-Variante. Aber da gucke ich gerade noch mal kurz.
Also ich war hier im Apple Store, da gibt es das nicht.
Ah, da gibt es das noch beide Varianten nicht. Weder als In-Ear-Kopfhörer, noch als...
Ich bin hier gleich irgendwie in Apple Store gelaufen, als ich hier in Toronto angekommen bin. Und da war da einfach nichts von zu sehen. Da konnten sie sich auch nicht Qualifize zu äußern. Ich habe die das natürlich gleich gefragt.
Ah, okay. Gut, dann wissen die, was sie sagen.
Also da können wir noch hoffen, weil da wären sie eigentlich schön doof, wenn sie das nicht reinbauen. Und das wäre wirklich gut. Weil das ist für mich eigentlich der einzige Grund, wenn ich durch die Gegend laufe und Podcasts höre, noch ans Gerät ranzufassen, ist die Lautstärke.
Genau, da hast du recht. Coming soon steht da, auch bei den normalen Bayern. Du hast recht. Auf der Apple-Seite.
Achso, bei den Apple-Headsets. Genau. Aber interessant ist natürlich, dass der iPod Touch damit im Prinzip auch zu einer VoIP-Plattform wird. Ja. So, dass sie wirklich ein Gerät haben, mit dem sie sich jetzt wirklich auch mal gegen die Telekom-Konzerne stellen könnten, theoretisch. Wenn es die entsprechende Infrastruktur gäbe. Ich meine, mit diesem Wi-Fi Everywhere, ich glaube, da sind wir noch wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr weit entfernt.
Das glaube ich auch.
Das gibt es hier auch in Toronto gerade wieder. Also das ist schon so ein bisschen Illusion. Und diese ganzen Hotspots, die sacken einfach wie Blöde, solange sie noch diesen ganzen bekloppten Webseiten orientierten Login-Scheiß haben. Also wenn die sich da nicht mal schnell auf irgendwas Übergreifendes, automatisch sich mit Kerberos oder sonst irgendwelchen Authentication, Autodiscovery-Methoden einigen können, dann wird sich das nie durchsetzen. Wobei die Telekom-Konzerne da auch nicht so die Motivation haben. Ich glaube, wir werden mit 3G noch ziemlich lange leben müssen. Aber was ich in dem Zusammenhang sehr interessant fand, die Meldung, dass Apple jetzt in Hongkong tatsächlich ein iPhone verkauft, unlockt, ohne Providerbindung, einfach so über den Apple Store. Man kann das online bestellen. Man kann bei Apple einfach sagen, ich möchte gerne für umgerechnet 470 Euro ein 8GB iPhone haben. Dann kriegt man das nach Hause geschickt und dann kann man jede beliebige SIM-Karte reinlegen. Also im Prinzip genau dieselben Dinge, wie sie sie in Italien verkaufen.
Kann ich aber nicht von hier bestellen, richtig?
Nein, du musst natürlich ein Hongkong-Resident sein. Das ist ja auch alles nachvollziehbar. Aber Hongkong ist ein extrem liberaler Markt. Auch 3G, nee 3 heißt ja der Provider, die da, also Hutchinson Telekom ist das glaube ich, die dort das iPhone auch offiziell verkaufen, verkaufen das Unlocked. Und 3 ist auch bekannt für niedrige Tarife und die wollen sozusagen den Telekom-Markt da von unten einfach durch bessere Angebote aufrollen. Ich denke da ist was in Bewegung und das zeigt auch, dass Apple nicht so an dieser Lösung klebt, mit anderen Providern unbedingt zu gehen. Ich denke sie machen das wirklich deshalb, weil sie eben automatisch die Vertriebsstruktur in diesen Ländern auch mitnutzen können. Wenn sie sich mit der Telekom ins Bett legen, dann haben sie halt auch die Infrastruktur dieser ganzen Telekom-Verkaufsstation. Und das ist eine der großen Argumente, warum sie das überhaupt machen. Natürlich kommt die Telekom und sagt, naja, dann muss es aber auch locked sein. Nur in relativ liberalen Märkten wie in Italien, wo die Kunden sowas gar nicht akzeptieren, wo die einfach sagen, wie gelockt ist das Telefon, habt ihr es noch alle? Wo es sich einfach nie durchgesetzt hat, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Da ist es dann halt auch anders. Oder in Belgien oder in Tschechien, genau.
Ich hab mir leider keins geholt, hatte keine Zeit mehr.
Dort ist keine Zeit mehr?
Nee, ich war nur einen Tag in Aachen.
Wir sind so ein bisschen am Rum überlegen, also so spremlich intern, ob wir probieren vielleicht mal sowas. Also es ist jetzt so unter Vorbehalt, vielleicht wollen sich ja schon ein paar Leute in den Kommentaren melden, eine iPhone-Butterfahrt zu organisieren.
Nach Italien?
Nach Prag. Nach Prag.
Du kriegst in Tschechien meines Wissens keine Prepaid-Verträge.
Du kriegst es nur mit Vertrag. Nee, es gibt das iPhone ohne Vertrag. Es steht zumindest auf der O2-Seite drauf.
Ach echt?
Ja, da haben wir schon mal drüber gesprochen. Da steht, wenn man auf die O2-Seite geht, zum Beispiel.
Na ja, da steht irgendwas auf Tschechisch, von dem keiner so genau wusste, was es denn nun wirklich heißt.
Das kann man in Google Talk schmeißen, dann weiß man, was es heißt. Und es hat sich seitdem auch noch ein bisschen geändert und ist ein bisschen eindeutiger geworden. Und was steht da? Ich suche es noch mal raus. iPhone. So, dann müssen hier irgendwo die... Giddyacu Peach ist es nicht. iPhone Balicci Asceni. Das heißt bestimmt Preise. Und...
Willkommen bei MobileMacs, wo sie ausländische Webseiten in Echtzeit übersetzt bekommen.
Ciena, iPhone, Ciena heißt Preise, iPhone 3G, Beers, ohne, Zavacu heißt dann wahrscheinlich, heißt dann wahrscheinlich mal Vertrag, nehme ich an, und dann steht ein Preis dahinter von, nämlich 8 GB Version, 11425.
Kannst du Tschechisch? Ich kann Russisch. Vielleicht heißt das irgendwie iPhone ohne Netzteil oder so.
Ne, ne, Ciena heißt Preis, so weit reicht man Russisch, und Zavacu kriege ich jetzt mal raus, was das heißt. Und da steht ein Preis dahinter, der dann so ungefähr bei den italienischen Preisen liegt und insofern behaupte ich mal einfach, das ist, das heißt so viel wie Preis des iPhones ohne Vertrag. Und in irgendwelchen diversen Foren habe ich auch schon gelesen, dass das auch schon gekauft worden ist und auch mit deutschen SIM-Kartenproblemen das funktioniert.
Ich habe mich ja über die belgischen iPhones erkundigt und also so, dass man wirklich nur das iTunes auf Belgisch schalten muss, um es einmal zu aktivieren. Und dann war für mich noch die Frage, ob dann, wenn die Updates kommen, ob man das dann immer wieder so machen muss, aber das muss man wohl nicht machen. Der Typ, der sich aus Belgien hat eins mitbringen lassen, der wurde von seinem deutschen iTunes dann irgendwie informiert, dass ein Update da ist. Er hat es dann automatisch gemacht und der musste da überhaupt gar nichts mehr auf Belgisch stellen. Das heißt, man macht das nur ein einziges Mal und dann ist schon alles prima. Also Belgien ist sozusagen auch noch nicht aus dem Rennen. Kann man auch sich in Belgien einzuholen. Das ist auch relativ nah für eine Menge Leute in Deutschland.
Und Zavaccu heißt Verpflichtung, was ich nehme an, so viel heißt wie Vertrag. Insofern würde ich behaupten, das ist der Preis des iPhones ohne Vertrag.
Gut, das kann natürlich alles sein.
Wie viel Euro sind es da? Das sind, ich guck mal nur für die große Variante, 13.425 Kronen und das sind, ding ding ding, ding ding ding, in Euro, sind das dann, blödes iPhone, 551,87 Euro.
Für die 16-Gig-Version.
Und das kleine, steht das da auch?
Das kleine sind 11.425 und das sind 469 Euro.
Also ein bisschen billiger als in Italien und Belgien.
Das ist so ziemlich genau der Preis, den man eben in Hongkong für das iPhone zahlt. Also das ist sozusagen wirklich ein, das ist dann auch ohne Prepaid, richtig?
Also es steht da iPhone Preis ohne Verpflichtung. Insofern würde ich sagen, da ist gar nichts dabei.
Weil deswegen sind sie nämlich in Italien auch ein bisschen teurer, weil da halt noch ein bisschen Prepaid-Guthaben dabei ist. Vermute ich jetzt mal. Also man kann eigentlich festhalten, 470 Euro ist dann etwa der Preis von einem 8 GB iPhone Retail ohne Subvention. So viel kostet das Teil.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, wann sie mit dem Ding mal in Deutschland rauskommen. Die meinten ja, dass irgendwann mal so ein Angebot kommt.
Irgendwann wird es vorbei sein mit diesen Verträgen, aber halt nicht so bald. Ich schätze mal, also zwei Jahre werden sie das sicherlich laufen lassen, insgesamt. Also jetzt noch auf jeden Fall ein Jahr. Aber nächsten Sommer, da würde ich jetzt meine Hand nicht für ins Feuer legen, ob dann diese ganze Geschichte noch genauso läuft. Weil letztlich ist das, wenn sie den Durchbruch auf den Märkten grundsätzlich erst mal erreicht haben und ich denke, da sind wir schon fast, dann können sie auch drauf scheißen. Dann brauchen sie irgendwie diese Marktpower nicht mehr. Aber weiß, weiß ich, wie sie das einschätzen. In den USA, Nordamerika haben sie einfach mit ihren Retail Stores eine Verkaufspower. Die ist groß, aber auch da tun sie sich ja jetzt auch schon mit anderen zusammen. Sie müssen, Telefone werden in Läden verkauft. Und das müssen sie halt auch in Europa irgendwie hinkriegen. Und nur mit einem Apple Store in München werden sie das sicherlich nicht gewuppt bekommen.
Gibt's den Store denn da jetzt schon?
Der hat noch nicht eröffnet, aber ich glaube, das ist bald soweit. Zu Tschechien kann man auch sagen, da gibt es ja seit kurzem eine neue Autobahn, sodass man von Dresden aus relativ easy nach Tschechien reinfahren kann. Die A17 ist da ausgebaut worden. Und dann ist man nach wenigen Kilometern in Užtí, das ist sozusagen dann der erste Ort hinter den Bergen. Das ist schon so ein größerer Ort, da sollte es sicherlich nur zwei Händler geben, wo man was kaufen kann. Da würden wir uns natürlich über Berichte freuen, sollte das jetzt mal wirklich einer machen.
Genau. Und wir probieren das nochmal aus, ob das auch alles geht.
Ja, wie sind denn eure Erfahrungen mit dem 2.1-Update?
Besser als das 2.0er, also vom Empfang her und so. Aber da ich zu Hause so schlechten Empfang habe, ist es hier bei mir immer noch beschissen. Aber es liegt halt an meinem schlechten Empfang hier. Aber ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob es mehr so ein Placebo-Effekt ist oder ob es wirklich besser ist. Weil manchmal sagt er, er hätte keinen Empfang. Also ein No Service zeigt an. Ich kann aber trotzdem eine SMS senden. Und manchmal zeigt er, er hätte einen Empfang. Aber ich kann keine SMS senden. Also es ist alles noch nicht so einheitlich. Aber irgendwie hatte ich schon das Gefühl, es ist ein bisschen besser als vorher.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Placebo, weil Empfangstechnik hat sich, wenn überhaupt, nur beim neuen iPhone was getan, oder? Wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Also ich habe jetzt für mich nicht so die großen Unterschiede bemerkt. Ich finde diese ganzen neuen iPod-Features, wobei, da kannst du bestimmt noch gleich ein bisschen mehr zu sagen, Tim, finde ich ganz großartig. Ich mag diese Genius-Funktion. Also das ist ein bisschen schlauerer Shuffle eigentlich. Das finde ich ganz hübsch bei mir. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr damit mal ein bisschen rumgeklickt habt, aber ihr habt ja alle keine Musik auf eurem iPhone insofern.
Ich habe keine Musik auf meinem iPhone und deswegen kann ich mit diesem Feature auch nichts anfangen.
Also das ist, man wählt ein Lied aus und kann dann andere Lieder, und geht dann auf diese Genius-Funktion und er sucht dann automatisch Lieder raus, die dazu passen, seiner Meinung nach. Das wird irgendwie aus den Verkaufszahlen des iPhones berechnet bei iTunes. Wer das gekauft hat, hat auch das gekauft. Dann muss das musikalisch zusammenpassen. Und das funktioniert ziemlich großartig eigentlich. Man hat da so eine hübsche Schafefunktion. Also es ist nicht perfekt, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man sagt, wow, was für eine grandiose Playlist. Aber man kann sich da mal spontan gut was zusammenstellen und muss nicht immer die gleiche Musik hören.
Ich glaube, das ist gut für Leute, die Filmmusik hören. Und das sind ja sicherlich die meisten.
So wie ich.
Genau. Also von Podcast-Juror ist es natürlich irgendwie sinnlos. Aber wobei das, das fände ich auch mal cool. Wenn man tatsächlich Podcast-Episoden anwählen kann und dann irgendwie gibt mir nochmal andere Podcast-Episoden, die so ähnlich geliebt werden.
Ich glaube, das geht nicht, oder?
Da fehlt einfach eins dieser Features, die ich schon immer gerne hätte, dass man einfach während man einen Podcast lauscht eben auch direkt auf dem Gerät ein Rating vergeben kann, was dann eben auch in diesen iTunes Podcast, Directory, Store, was auch immer zurückfließt in irgendeiner Form. Also wir sind natürlich jetzt schon beim heißen Thema. Und zwar einerseits die neuen Funktionen für Podcasting und dann müssen wir natürlich auf jeden Fall über die große Kontroverse nochmal reden, auch wenn es jetzt schon ein altes Ei ist, hier mit der Podcaster-Application.
Stimmt. Was konnten die denn überhaupt?
Na ja, lass uns mal vielleicht nochmal kurz bei den 2.1 Features bleiben, weil kurz nachdem ich sozusagen da meinen Rand abgesetzt habe in der letzten Sendung, hat Steve sozusagen sofort die Handbremse gezogen und gesagt, Tim hat sich beklagt, wir müssen da was tun. Und siehe da, tatsächlich war in der 2.1 tatsächlich mal, sind das erste Mal seit langer, langer Zeit explizit für Podcast neue Features. Erstens im iTunes natürlich, dass man jetzt endlich im iTunes 8 pro Podcast diese Settings einstellen kann. Ich finde die immer noch nicht elaboriert genug. Mir fehlt da so ein bisschen noch mindestens eine weitere Einstellung, damit man etwas genauer kontrollieren kann, wann er etwas wegwirft. Aber es ist gegenüber dem vorherigen globalen Setting ein Riesenvorteil. Wer mehr als zehn Podcasts abonniert hat, der hat gekotzt. Sagen wir mal so was wie Tagesthemen, wenn du das abonniert hast, da will ich nicht die letzten 20 Sendungen vorrätig halten. Sondern ein oder zwei vielleicht. Aber was interessiert mich der Schnee von gestern? Und wenn man das mal eine Weile nicht hört, dann will man den alten Kram nicht archivieren. Das kann man jetzt zumindest etwas geschmeidiger machen. Aber andere Podcasts wiederum, da will ich jede Episode hören. Und da möchte ich eben auch nicht, dass er die alten wegschmeißt. Und da möchte ich dann ein Setting machen, okay, auch wenn ich es jetzt mal eine Weile nicht gehört habe, bitte nicht nur die letzten paar. Und jetzt kann man das zumindest etwas geschmeidiger machen. Das ging meiner Meinung nach noch etwas geschmeidiger, aber ich will mich jetzt hier nicht in den letzten Details verfangen. Was interessant ist, dass sie auf dem iPhone selber auch einiges verbessert haben. Aber um es gleich noch dazu zu sagen, meiner Meinung nach haben sie auch etwas verschlimmert. Was nämlich richtig nervt, was also richtig scheiße ist, was einfach gar nicht geht, ist, wenn du über das Podcast-Menü in der iPod-Anwendung gehst. Also iPod und dann wählst du Podcasts aus und dann kriegst du halt eine Liste aller Podcasts. Das sieht jetzt schick aus, gleich mit dem Cover dabei und so weiter. Der Titel, das ist super. Er sagt, wie viele Episoden da sind. Das ist super. Ob da schon was, ob da noch was Ungehörtes ist, das ist auch toll. Das war ja auch vorher schon so. Richtig gut ist, dass wenn man jetzt eine einzelne Episode schon gehört hat, dass er sagt, die hast du angefangen zu hören. Und er zeigt mir direkt an, wie viel noch zu hören ist. Das ist einfach für lange Podcasts, ist das wirklich super.
Das ist dieser blaue Button, der auch zur Not halb voll ist, dass man weiß, man ist so mittendrin.
Genau. Also er zeigt jetzt nicht wirklich exakt so eine Tortengrafik an, wo man jetzt ist, sondern ist halt einfach halb im Sinne von, hast du schon mal angehört, aber du bist noch nicht zu Ende. Das finde ich auch vollkommen in Ordnung. Und dazu schreibt er auch noch, das war schon mehr als ich jetzt erwartet hätte, wie viel noch zu hören ist. Er zeigt gleich in der Übersicht an, wie lange eine Episode ist. Das ist auch ein Riesenvorteil. Das heißt, bevor man anfängt zu hören, sieht man, ah, okay, die würde jetzt zwei Stunden gehen, ist jetzt nicht zumutbar. Da habe ich noch so eine 30-Minuten-Episode, die kriege ich jetzt in der nächsten Bahnfahrt noch unter. Und das Datum wird angezeigt. Also soweit ist es wirklich klasse. Ich hatte am Anfang allerdings extreme Probleme noch mit dem Zurücksinken und so. Grundsätzlich hat sich mit der 2.1 bei mir auch viel verbessert. Also Akkulaufzeit ist gefühlt, kann ich nicht so zahlen, aber viel, viel besser geworden.
Die Backup-Zeit.
Ja, da braucht man gar nicht drüber reden. Also das ist jetzt einfach so, wie es sein soll.
Ja, also langsam wird das iPhone mit iPhone 2.1 geht es jetzt langsam in die Richtung, wie man es eigentlich bei der 2.0 hätte.
Aber hier das so träge ist das iPhone. Am Anfang hatte ich auch das Gefühl, boah, ist jetzt alles schnell und flutscht und es ist toll. Aber jetzt, ich weiß nicht, wie lange es jetzt her, zwei Wochen oder so, habe ich schon wieder, ich öffne die Contacts und dauert so zwei Sekunden, wo der Bildschirm einfach nur so mit diesem grauen Muster ist, also ohne alles, und dann dauert es zwei Sekunden, bis überhaupt erstmal was kommt. Also es ist wieder so wie vorher, finde ich.
Also die SMS-Applikation, die braucht bei mir, die wird immer unglaublich langsam.
Aber es war am Anfang schnell, es kommt so mit der Zeit, und ich habe eigentlich gar nichts gemacht, also meine Contacts sind jetzt nicht irgendwie hunderttausende mehr, sondern sind vielleicht zwei, drei dazugekommen. Deswegen wundert es mich ein bisschen, was das auf Dauer so langsam macht. Muss man da auch irgendwie mal booten, oder was ist das?
Also, booten bringt dann in dem Fall nicht mehr sonderlich viel, habe ich das Gefühl. Das kann man ja fast nur mal ausprobieren, fällt mir gerade auf. Sollte ich es vielleicht mal ein bisschen weiter von hier weghalten. Aber ja, keine Ahnung, woran das liegt. Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, dass da die Datenbank anfängt zu sprinten, zu spinnen oder irgendwie sowas. Aber...
Das werden wir jetzt nicht geklärt bekommen. Lass mich noch mal kurz diese Podcast-Geschichte zu Ende bringen. Ich beeile mich auch. So weit, so gut. Jetzt, was ist schlecht? Also, erstmal, er zeigt bei den Episoden groß, also wenn er die Episoden eines Podcasts auflässt, zeigt er groß als erstes den Autor an. Das ist besonders komisch, weil meiner Meinung nach sollte ja der Titel der Episode im Mittelpunkt stehen. Der Titel steht da drunter. Dadurch, dass er etwas kleiner ist, passt auch mehr Text hin, aber lange Titel sind immer noch nicht zu lesen. Also er scrollt nach wie vor nicht von links nach rechts durch. Sprich, man weiß nicht, was Sache ist. Was sie allerdings jetzt dazu bewogen hat, bei Podcasts den angegebenen Autor so nach vorne zu stellen, ist mir vollkommen unklar, weil bei den meisten Episoden steht da immer das Gleiche drin. Also man steht da und steht halt irgendwie Tim Maxx und Dennis drin. Und das ändert sich halt nicht. Von daher finde ich diese Entscheidung bekloppt. Was mich richtig nervt, ist, dass wenn man jetzt einen Podcast hört und der ist zu Ende, dass er dann automatisch wie in einer Playlist in die nächste Episode geht. Was kein iPod vorher gemacht hat und auch das iPhone vorher nicht gemacht hat.
Das finde ich auch ziemlich nervig, aber es gibt Leute, die freuen sich wie Sau darüber.
Ich habe nichts dagegen, dass man das einstellen kann, weil es mag vielleicht für manche Podcasts so sein. Aber ich will bewusst einfach eine Sendung zu Ende hören. Und wenn die dann zu Ende ist, will ich entscheiden, welche ich als nächstes anbreche. So. Und wenn er mir dann direkt reingeht, es gibt so Sachen, da weißt du nicht, da kriegst du überhaupt nicht mit, dass es zu Ende ist. Wenn ihr zum Beispiel hier so Deutschlandradio, Hintergrundpolitik, ja, höre ich sehr gerne. Das sind so knackige 18 Minuten. Und das ist halt so Radio, weißt du? Die fangen immer so kantig an und die hören so kantig auf. Und wenn du dann zwei Episoden hintereinander hörst, da kriegst du überhaupt nicht mit, dass die eine Episode zu Ende ist. Weil die sagen nicht am Schluss, ja, tschüss und bis zum nächsten Mal. Sondern irgendwie, ja, da ist dann irgendwie noch mal so ein Kommentar von irgendjemand, so und Chechenien stellt sich diese Frage nicht mehr. So, und dann geht's halt gleich weiter mit. Werder Bremen ist wie ein Verein der besonderen Art. So und dann, weißt du, dann denk ich mir so, was hat Werder Bremen mit Chechenien zu tun? Und merkt das dann halt erst irgendwie zwei Minuten später. And this doesn't help. Also das ist einfach nicht cool. Das müssen sie ändern. Ich bin nicht dafür. Und dieses automatisch rotieren Ding, was ich letztes Mal so beklagt habe.
Automatisch rotieren Ding?
Na ja, du weißt schon, man liegt im Bett.
Ach so, ja klar. Dass sich das Display dreht und wenn man das Gerät auf die Seite dreht.
Genau, da gibt es jetzt ein Workaround. Und das ist auch wieder komisch, weil wenn du in der iPod-Applikation auf Videos gehst, dann sind da nicht nur deine Filme, sondern da tauchen jetzt auch alle Video-Podcast-Episoden auf. Zusätzlich noch, warum auch immer. Da dachte ich mir so, was denn das für ein Scheiß. Aber das Interessante ist, wenn du eine Podcast-Episode, eine Video-Podcast-Episode über Videos auswählst und nicht über Podcasts, dann spielt er sie immer im Querformat ab und dann dreht er auch nicht mehr. Das heißt, Filme drehen nicht, Podcasts drehen. Warum auch immer. Also das ist maßlos inkonsistent und ich verstehe das überhaupt nicht. Aber es ist zumindest insofern eine Hilfe, als dass man sich jetzt zum Schlafengehen nochmal mit irgendwas berieseln kann, ohne die ganze Zeit das Teil so auf 41 Grad kurz bevor der Accelerometer anschlägt, halten muss, was vollkommen beknackt ist. Also das sind so meine Beobachtungen, die ich jetzt hier gemacht habe mit dem 2.1-Update. Im Prinzip Riesen, Sprung nach vorne. Das Telefon ist jetzt irgendwie so, wie man sich das so denkt. Ich bin extrem zufrieden.
Die neue Version, die 2.2-A-Beta, wird jetzt schon an die Entwickler verteilt. Da gibt es auch schon erste Screenshots, wo sich Safari ein bisschen verändert hat. Da im Wesentlichen bei der Bedienung. Aber ich nehme mal an, die eigentlichen Unterschiede wären unter der Haube liegen. Das Dev-Team hat schon wieder gesagt, ja, wir haben es schon wieder gehackt, aber es läuft schon, wir kriegen es schon wieder gehackt.
Die Frage ist, wann Apple hier mit diesem API-Zusatz oder Change rauskommt, mit diesem Background-Application. Da müssen sie ja auch mal was fixen. Wobei sich inzwischen auch schon gar keiner mehr beschwert. Dass Programme so eine Background-API benutzen können, um sich Infos holen zu lassen, ohne dass alle Programme ihre eigene Connection haben, sondern das iPhone hat halt nur noch eine und die Programme bedienen sich über diese eine Connection.
Diese Notification-API.
Genau.
Da gab es halt diese angebliche E-Mail-Antwort von Steve Jobs, wo er meinte, ja, ja, we wanna get this right from the start.
Na, da kann ich mir, ich kann ja nur mutmaßen, was der Grund ist, warum sie es wieder entfernt haben, aber wer schon einmal dieses Push-Mail auf dem iPhone eingeschaltet hat, was ja eigentlich eine sehr hübsche Funktion ist, aber dann mitbekommen hat, wie unglaublich schnell das den Akku leer saugt, ich glaube, das ist so eine Vorahnung daraus, was uns blühen könnte, wenn diese Notification-API kommt.
Ich denke, sie haben es einfach Steve Jobs auf den Tisch gelegt und haben gesagt, hier guck mal, und er hat gesagt, was ist das für ein Scheiß, schließt euch noch mal zwei Wochen ein oder vier.
Ja, aber es muss ja Gründe dafür geben.
Natürlich, es funktioniert einfach nicht gut. Ich meine, wenn sie damit rauskommen mit diesem Framework, dann ist das sozusagen bindend, da werden zahlreiche Dienste werden dafür Backends entwickeln. Es wird Java-Server-Dienste geben, die halt ein iPhone-Backend haben und so weiter, damit das eben unterstützt wird. AIM und so weiter. Das heißt, da hängt unglaublich viel ab. Und wenn sie das jetzt am Anfang so Mobile-Meme-mäßig verkacken, dann haben sie ein Problem. Und ich denke, sie sind jetzt einfach sehr, sehr, sehr vorsichtig geworden, dass sie dieses Jahr nicht noch mal so einen Heuler rausbringen, weil davon haben sie jetzt einfach genug abgeliefert.
Ja, das wär wirklich langsam ein bisschen viel.
Und dazu kommen natürlich, dazu müssen wir auf jeden Fall jetzt nochmal was sagen, diese ganze Kontroverse mit dem Application Store. Ich meine, auch der war am Anfang eher mau, weil er sehr viel mehr an einen, was er auch war, an einen Music Store, der jetzt auch Programme runterladen lässt, erinnert. Und naja, mittlerweile wird es ja langsam besser. Die Entwickler haben ihre Statistiken und wie ich jetzt gerade eben gelesen habe, können jetzt auch Leute nur noch dann ein Review einer Applikation abgeben, wenn sie das auch gekauft haben bzw. runtergeladen haben, wenn es frei war.
Das ist aber eigentlich okay.
Das ist eine super Änderung, weil natürlich sonst die Leute sich immer über den Preis beschweren und irgendwie eine geringe Wertung abgeben, was überhaupt nichts aussagt. Ich meine, sie müssen das eh noch verbessern, weil man kann sich auch nicht auf eine Version beziehen und dann sagt einer, mir fehlt aber Feature XY oder das funktioniert nicht. Eine Woche später ist das Update draußen und alles ist wunderbar, aber dann steht dieses Review da immer noch so drin. Das ist alles noch nicht so richtig.
Die Anzahl der Downloads haben sie jetzt ja entfernt. Wo früher mal Null stand, haben sie einfach jetzt rausgenommen.
Da hatte ich noch gar nicht gesehen. Das ist ja auch bekloppt. Es wird langsam besser. Was ich interessant finde, ist jetzt auch in dem Zusammenhang mit dem Review, Apple weiß, was du gekauft hast. Und wenn du dir eine Applikation aus deinem iTunes löscht und aus deinem iPhone löscht, also richtig löscht, löscht, löscht weg, dann kannst du das nochmal runterladen, ohne neu bezahlen zu müssen.
Das ging aber von Anfang an so.
Ja, aber nur bei Programmen. Warum geht denn das nicht bei meiner Musik? Und es ist doch dieselbe Store-Infrastruktur. Also das verstehe ich nicht. Das sollten sie auch dann gleich mal für Musik einschalten, weil das machen auch andere Stores.
Ah, da fällt mir in dem Zusammenhang was ein. Du hattest ja dieses, hatten wir letztes Mal drüber geredet, dass iTunes die Musik erst lokal verschlüsselt, hattest du gesagt, ne?
Das war meine Vermutung, ja.
Das war deine Vermutung. Da hat sich irgendwie einer der Leser, das finde ich jetzt natürlich nicht, weil meine Newswire gerade nicht laufen will, der hat sich das einfach mal mit Wireshark angeguckt, was da an Daten kommt und hat festgestellt. Ist zu anderen Ergebnissen gekommen. Die Musik wird verschlüsselt übertragen.
Ja klar, mit SSA, aber...
Nein, er kann die Daten abfangen. Die Musik ist schon per DRM geschützt gewesen. Aber die Coverbilder sind noch nicht drin gewesen. Die werden tatsächlich erst im Nachhinein reingepackt. Die Datei wird von iTunes noch mal geändert, aber das DRM ist schon drauf.
Ich setze den nicht, dass ich das jetzt... Das war auch so ein bisschen Hörensagen, was ich davon mir gegeben habe. Ich kann keine Quelle nennen, von daher kann es sein, dass ich von Anfang an falsch lag. Meiner Meinung nach war es mal so. Und es kann gut sein, dass sie das mit irgendeinem iTunes-Release geändert haben. Ja gut, aber nochmal zum Upstore. Jetzt gab es eine Menge Ärger.
Genau.
Weil halt in zunehmendem Maße Applikationen rausgekommen sind. Natürlich hat sich das ganz besonders entzündet an...
Abgewiesen worden sind meinst du?
Richtig, abgewiesen worden sind. Ganz besonders hat sich das entzündet in diesem Fall dieser Applikation Podcaster, der eine Podcasting, Listening und Download-Applikation geschrieben hat, die halt im Gegensatz zu der Funktionalität von iTunes, iPhone, iPod eben die Podcasts auch direkt aufs Gerät laden kann über das Internet. Nur Funktionalität, wo man sagen würde...
Ja, will ich auch haben.
Will man haben. Ich würde das nicht für alle meine Podcasts haben wollen, aber ich fänd's gut, wenn man das zumindest für bestimmte Podcasts sagen kann, okay, die ändern sich am laufenden Meter, da möchte ich gerne, dass mein iPhone die runterlädt und nicht mein iTunes.
Genau, das wär großartig.
Ich denke, wenn Apple so ein Feature einbaut, dann müssten sie das auch irgendwie so drehen, weil du kannst ja vom iTunes auf mehrere Geräte sinken. Das heißt, du müsstest dann schon auch sagen, welches dieser Geräte den Podcast runterlädt, weil sonst wird er natürlich n-mal runtergeladen. Das kann weder im Sinne des Anwenders sein, noch im Sinne des Podcasters sein. Weil wenn dann irgendwie jeder Hörer sozusagen dreimal runterlädt, ist halt auch irgendwie doof.
Ich würde sagen, da wo er als erstes auf Upgrade klickt, oder? Aber das würde sich nicht klingen.
Aber wenn du mit deinem iPhone rumläufst und dein iTunes läuft zu Hause, dann wissen die ja nichts voneinander, dass die beide an der gleichen Source rumnagen. Das ist ja das Ding. Die sind ja dann nicht mehr miteinander verbunden. Das Problem gibt es mit dem derzeitigen Modell nicht.
Ja, aber du hast das Modell, das ist natürlich nicht ganz so schlimm, aber ich meine, das hast du ja im App Store auch. Wenn du ein Programm aktualisierst, kannst du das ja auch auf beiden Geräten aktualisieren.
Gut, aber da reden wir über Dateien. Die sind so 0,3 Megabyte groß bis maximal 25. Und bei Podcasts, und dann ist es auch für die Statistik irrelevant, weil es geht über einen bestimmten Account. Apple weiß, dass du das dann eben auf dem iPhone runtergeladen hast und so weiter. Und beim Syncing geht das alles auf. Aber der Podcaster weiß das ja nicht, wenn er auf einmal dreimal so viele Downloads hat, aber nur deshalb, weil die Hörer sozusagen mit ihrem iTunes und ihrem iPhone und ihrem iPod Touch runterladen.
Das stimmt, das ist zugegebenermaßen tatsächlich ein Problem, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das das Problem ist, dass Apple davon abhält.
Das glaube ich auch nicht. Ich glaube, das sind einfach grundsätzliche Erwägungen mit der Art und Weise, wie man mit Bandwidth umgeht. Aber auch, dass sie eben solche User-Workflow-Sachen sozusagen noch nicht als gelöst sehen. Wie auch immer, diese Applikation ist submitted worden in den App Store von dem Entwickler. Apple hat sich das angeschaut oder wer auch immer und hat gesagt, Duplicates Functionality of iTunes war glaube ich die Formulierung.
Dabei stimmt es ja gar nicht so genau, ne?
Na ja, insofern stimmt es, als dass es die Distribution von Podcasts sozusagen übernimmt. Da gab es ja auch einen richtigen Kampf. Also der Gruber und der Dilger von roughlydrafted.com vertreten da ja wirklich diametral gegenüberstehende Meinungen, was sehr interessant ist, wo sie sich ja sonst eigentlich bei so vielen Sachen immer einig sind. Ich bin da so ein bisschen hin und hergerissen. Ich meine, ich kann da irgendwie beide Seiten ganz gut verstehen. Ich muss auch dazu sagen, ich habe mir die Applikation dann gekauft, weil ich wollte mir einfach das Ding mal angucken. Er hat ja dann, da er nicht im App Store ist, diese Ad-hoc-Distributionsmethode gebraucht oder man muss eigentlich fast sagen missbraucht. Das heißt, ich habe mir meine Device-ID rausgekramt, die steht ja im iTunes, wenn du das iPhone anschließt oder den iPod Touch, dann im iTunes, wenn das Ding erscheint, in der Übersicht, in der Info-Übersicht, im Summary steht deine Seriennummer und wenn du auf Serial-Number klickst, dann schaltet der um und zeigt dir deine ID an. Das ist so ein irrelanger Hextring, den man da auch an der Stelle nicht copy-pasten kann. Wenn du Xcode installiert hast, dann kriegst du das Ding auch in copy-pastable Formen, aber so müsste man es halt abtippen. Und dann habe ich halt diese ID ihm geschickt über so ein Web-Formular. Dann haben sie gesagt, okay, jetzt überweis mal Geld. Dann habe ich Geld überwiesen, Paypal oder so. Und nach ein paar Tagen habe ich dann eine Mail bekommen, jetzt kannst du es dir runterladen. Ich bin dann nochmal auf die Webseite gegangen, nochmal meine E-Mail-Adresse eingetragen, und sie hat gesagt, okay, alles klar, du hast bezahlt. Und vor allem liegt das jetzt für dich vor. Weil was ja ein Entwickler machen muss, er muss diese ID nehmen, muss die ID bei Apple über das Developer-Interface mit iTunes eintragen in diese Mobile-Provision-Datei, die man dann mitbekommt. Das ist so eine Art Datei, wo eben gesigned drinsteht, von Apple, ja, dieser Developer darf auch auf diesem Device diese Applikation installieren. Und darüber konnte ich das dann eben bei mir lokal installieren. Das ist natürlich, diese Ad-Hoc-Geschichte ist halt eher so für Beta-Tester gedacht, für kleinere Gruppen.
Ich hab immer sagen lassen, das sind so unglaublich aufwendig sein, diese Ad-Hoc-Methode. Also das ist wirklich viel, viel Arbeit auch für den Entwickler. Also der hat dafür deine 10 Dollar, hat er da richtig Arbeit gemacht, sich gemacht.
Ja, da gehen sehr viel mit Zertifikaten hin und her und das ist nicht einfach, wobei ich mir gut vorstellen kann, dass die diesen Workflow auch noch ein bisschen optimiert bekommen. Das ist anstrengend, aber es ist ja auch nicht dafür gedacht, an große Gruppen, mit denen du nur temporär was zu tun hast, zu distributieren, sondern es ist ja für gedacht, dass wenn du eben eine definierte Menge an iPods oder iPod Touches in deiner Entwicklerfirma hast, dass du die eben da einträgst und dann kannst du eben dafür deine Applikationen auch machen. Das heißt, du machst das ja nicht jedes Mal immer wieder komplett neu. Aber was er gemacht hat, ist, dass er quasi immer sein Quorum von 100 Applikationen voll ausgereizt hat und dann eine Änderung an der Applikation gemacht hat und als neue Applikation eingestellt hat und dann wieder dafür 100 gemacht hat. Und er hat, glaube ich, 1.100 Lizenzen oder so verkauft bekommen. Also hat er irgendwie schon seine 11.000 Dollar gemacht, die alle als Donation deklariert waren, im Übrigen. Bis ihm dann wohl Apple jetzt vor ein paar Tagen da den Hahn abgedreht hat, weil das eben einfach eine Violation auf... Was soll man da für...
Und du bist jetzt her und her gerissen, ob das von Apple okay ist oder nicht?
Na ja, es gibt da zwei Positionen. Die Position eins ist die... Die Schreierei hatten wir ja hier auch schon. Der Markt muss offen sein. Let the users decide, how dare you Apple, wie könnt ihr irgendwie darüber richten, was wir für Anwendungen für eure Plattform schreiben. Das ist so die eine Sichtweise. Das muss ja alles ganz offen sein und überhaupt und was fällt euch überhaupt ein. Und wir finden eure Kriterien scheiße. Beziehungsweise wir finden, das ist auch, sagen wir mal, der berechtigte Teil. Wo ich sagen würde, uneingeschränkt teile ich diese Ansicht. Apple hat es bisher nicht verstanden, diese Kriterien, die sie anlegen, auch auf eine Art und Weise zu kommunizieren, dass die Entwickler schon vorher wissen, wovon sie die Finger lassen sollen. Ihr erinnert euch bei dieser Keynote, da gab es diese Liste, was sie alles nicht haben wollen, Porn und Bandwithhawk und Tralala. Dann gab es aber auch diese schöne Kategorie Unforeseen. Unvorhergesehene Dinge. Das war sozusagen das Sternpunkt Stern der Ablehnenkandidaten. Das erleben wir jetzt hier. Ich denke, die haben einfach diese Applikation gesehen und haben sich gefragt, was ist hier los? Dann gab es jetzt eine lange Diskussion im Netz darüber, welcher Paragraph dieses Vertrages, den die Developer dort abschließen mit dem SDK, greift hier. Da gibt es diese, sagen wir mal, umwobene 3.3-Klausel, wo halt drin steht, man darf halt kein Distributionsmedium, was eben iTunes kopiert, sozusagen nachbilden. Sie wollen das einfach nicht. So, und jetzt? Wollt ihr vielleicht erstmal was zu sagen? Ich halte schon wieder monologe.
Also ich halte das für relativ unhaltbar, und zwar aus Sicht des Entwicklers einfach mal. Also für einen iPhone-Entwickler, der sich hinsetzt, wochenlang, monatelang Arbeit in Kauf nimmt, um dann das Programm einzureichen bei Apple, um dann zu hören, ah nee, lass mal. Das ist kein Zustand. Da muss Apple ganz, ganz dringend was dran ändern. Das darf nicht passieren. Das ist, ich meine, für den ist ja echt, mag sein, dass das jetzt so eine nette Anekdote ist, dass er seit 11.000 Dollar damit ein bisschen Arbeit für gemacht hat. Aber der hätte in der Zeit vielleicht noch 50.000 Dollar machen können. Und wer weiß, er muss ja auch in der Zeit sich irgendwo von ernähren. Also das ist ja nicht alles nur Spaß.
Na vor allem hat er ja auch Zeit investiert. Also ich meine, du legst halt los, programmierst, sagen wir, drei Monate, vielleicht das Supertool, stellst es halt rein, willst auch nicht mit einem Beta-Zeugs anfangen, weil du willst halt gleich richtig mit einer 1.0 rauskommen, hast dir voll die Arbeit und dann sagen die, ach nö, das ist schon, das geht nicht.
Vor allem, du hast ja vorher auch keine Chance bei Apple mal nachzufragen, hey, hätte ich denn damit mal eine Chance? Sondern du musst ja erstmal diese Arbeit in Kauf nehmen und das ist eine reine Lotterie.
Das weiß ich nicht, ob das nicht so ist, dass er keine Chance hätte. Also in dem Fall war es wohl so, dass er sich vorher nicht mit Apple auseinandergesetzt hat. Soweit ich die Diskussion verfolgt habe, hat er nicht vorher gefragt. Er hat einfach entwickelt und dann hat er es submitted und dann gab es diese Antwort.
Du kannst ja auch nicht für jedes App irgendwie nachfragen. Hast du eine super tolle Idee? Und dann verrätst du denen die erst mal und dann denken die sich auch gleich, na, da können wir auch gleich selber machen. Die ist ja super cool, die Idee. Also man braucht ja so ein bisschen...
Ja gut, aber ich meine, wenn die Leute uns auch eine Antwort kriegen.
Also die Entwickler kriegen am Augenblick nicht mal mitgeteilt, wenn ihre App eingestellt worden ist, endgültig, sondern scheinen das ja auch mehr oder weniger per Zufall alles mitzubekommen. So ja, möglicherweise ist es in wenigen Tagen da und dann ist es plötzlich schon da. Insofern glaube ich, wenn man Apple vorher eine Mail schreibt, so ich habe vor, das und das Programm zu entwickeln, ich glaube, da wird sich niemand die Arbeit machen, die sich die Mail auch noch durchzulesen bei Apple.
Da stochern wir jetzt, also bei Podcastern, worum es jetzt konkret ging, war es einfach so, dass er nicht vorher gefragt hat. So und der andere Punkt, den ich an der Stelle beleuchten möchte, ich versuche das ja auch mal so ein bisschen ausgewogen von beiden Seiten zu sehen. Wenn du jetzt eine Applikation schreibst und die lädt Porn runter, dann kannst du einfach total davon ausgehen, dass die abgelehnt wird. Weil du das schon vorher weißt. Mit anderen Worten, es gibt Kriterien in diesem SDK-Vertrag, die dir sagen, was nicht akzeptiert werden wird. Und jetzt ist eigentlich nur die Diskussion, ist für diese Applikation Podcaster mit den Features, die da drin waren, ist es vorher klar gewesen, dass es abgelehnt wird oder nicht? Ich denke, es war nicht mit Sicherheit zu sagen, dass es abgelehnt werden wird, aber es ist auch schon so, dass man natürlich damit rechnen muss, dass man mit Apple an der Stelle in den Konflikt kommt.
Also es gibt ja noch eine zweite Applikation, die auch abgelehnt worden ist, mit einer ähnlichen Begründung, dass sie eine Funktionalität duplizieren würde, die schon drin ist. Das ist dieses Mail Wrangler, habt ihr wahrscheinlich mitbekommen. Das ist ein Programm, das im Wesentlichen wirklich extrem billig einem nichts weiter tut, als die entsprechenden, dass man mehrere Google-Mail-Accounts verwalten kann, indem es einfach mehrere Cookie-Sets sich irgendwie abspeichert und dann einem nichts weiter macht, als die Webseite zu präsentieren. Sozusagen, damit man immer aufs Gmail-Interface zugreifen kann, ohne sich mehrfach ein- und ausloggen zu müssen. Und das ist auch abgelehnt worden. Und das ist so was, das ist...
Ja, aber das ist doch aus dem gleichen... Na warum? Weil es gibt diese Mail-Applikationen schon auf dem iPhone, mit dem man mehrere Google-Mail-Accounts einrichten kann.
Welche?
Na Mail.
Aber Mail kann ich nicht aufs Web-Interface drauf zugreifen.
Nein, aber du greifst auf deinen Google-Mail-Account zu. Ich meine, ob du da nur ein Web-View kriegst oder ob du da einen View kriegst, der von deinem Programm grennt. Das ist jetzt nämlich genau der Punkt, an der sich das, wo ich glaube, sich Apple auch wirklich Gedanken macht. Sie wollen halt User-Confusion verhindern. Das unterstelle ich ihnen jetzt einfach mal, dass das für sie ein ganz wichtiger Punkt ist. Weil sie kein Interesse daran haben, dass es Software gibt, die die Leute verwirrt oder die Leute aus sonst irgendwelchen Gründen von dieser Plattform abstößt. Wie auch dieses I Am Rich zum Beispiel der Plattform geschadet hat, weil es einfach ausgetrieben wird.
Also da gibt es auch gar keine Irritation, weil die Leute wollen es doch bewusst haben.
Du weißt immer erst am Ende nach dem Kauf, was du wirklich kriegst.
Na ja, grob steht das ja schon da. Und bei diesen Podcasts kann ich nicht so verstehen, was der Grund ist von Apple, weil sie keine Konkurrenz wollen. Dann sollen sie es direkt so hinschreiben. Aber selbst dann kann ich es nicht verstehen. Sie verdienen an dem Programm sogar mit. Sie könnten selber ihr Podcasting-Features irgendwie aufwerten. Also ich kann das Problem nicht richtig sehen.
Ich kann dir das Problem sagen. Ich habe die Applikation ja dann gekauft und ich habe sie installiert und habe sie benutzt. Und also erstens, ich habe jetzt keine Update-Notifikation bekommen. Es gab einfach nur diese eine einzige Version. Seitdem ist da nichts wieder passiert. Diese Applikation taugt nichts. Das kann ich dir einfach mal sagen.
Davon gibt es tausend andere, die Apple noch nicht abgelehnt hat. Das kann nicht das Argument sein.
Na ja, also pass auf. Also was ich gemacht habe, ist, ich wollte halt irgendwie Chaos Radio Express mal abonnieren. Das war so mein erster Test, klar. Logisch. Man nimmt erst mal seinen eigenen Podcast. Und die erste Möglichkeit ist, dass du da halt irgendwie suchst. Das heißt, du hast da irgendeine Search, da hab ich Chaos Radio Express eingegeben, taucht er auch tatsächlich auf. Da hab ich mich schon mal gefragt, wo sucht denn der eigentlich? Ist vollkommen unklar, in welchem Directory der sucht. Da gab's dann einen Result, einen, den hab ich dann irgendwie auch abonnieren können. Ich hab nicht herausfinden können, was der da abonniert hat, welchen Feed der da abonniert hat. Und dann hat er mir irgendwie eine Liste von Episoden angezeigt, wo ich mir nur noch am Kopf gekratzt hab. Das war ein Wüstersammelsurium von random Episoden aus meinem Podcast, wo die nicht in der richtigen Reihenfolge angezeigt wurden, wo überhaupt nicht klar war, was da der neueste und der älteste ist, so wie er es mir angezeigt hat. Ich konnte danach auch nicht, nachdem ich den einmal hinzugefügt habe, konnte ich den auch nicht mehr löschen oder bearbeiten oder sonst irgendwas. Also dieses Programm ist einfach broken. Und das Abspielinterface dann wiederum, und er speichert ja diese ganzen Podcasts in seiner Sandbox, weil das ja so ist. Das Abspielinterface war dann wiederum eine weitgehende Kopie des iPod-Abspielinterfaces. Das heißt, das ist für Apple auch ein Grund, Duplicates Functionality, weil natürlich es so ähnlich aussieht wie das normale iPod-Interface, aber ein komplett anderes, doppeltes Interface ist, wo dann Leute halt auch hergehen und sagen, wieso geht denn das jetzt nicht mehr was vorher ging und wenn ich über iPod reingehe, kann ich diese Podcasts nicht sehen, weil die gehen dann auf Podcasts, weil sie haben ja Podcasts, da haben sie Podcasts runtergeladen, gehen dann mit iPod in Podcasts und da sind dann diese Podcasts nicht.
Patin, das ist doch albern.
Das ist doch nicht...
Na doch, in dem Moment, in dem ich hingehe und mir ein Programm kaufe, das mir ein zusätzliches Eigen installiert, weiß ich doch grob, was die Funktionalität vorher war, wo ich die vorher zu finden hatte und wo ich sie danach zu finden habe.
Nee, das wissen Leute nicht. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich find das auch total scheiße. Weil du lädst ja dann aus dem iTunes Store so eine Podcast-Applikation runter, die sagt, jetzt kannst du deine Podcasts auch übers Web laden. Und dann hast du aber zwei Orte, wo deine Podcasts sind. Ich mein, das ist ja schon mit der iPod-Applikation verwirrend genug.
Aber dann hätte Apple hinschreiben müssen, wir wollen keine schlechte Software im Store. Aber dafür haben sie ganz andere Sachen zugelassen. Also ich find, das Argument zieht nicht. Vor allem, weil es wahrscheinlich mehr Leute dieses Podcaster-Programm runtergeladen bei Apple so einen Alarm macht, als hätten sie einfach mal die Klappe gehalten. Der hätte sich von ganz alleine rumgesprochen. Das ist nicht so tolles.
Und ich meine, nehmen wir dieses Remote-Programm, was Apple mitliefert, zum Beispiel diese Fernbedienung, die sieht auch aus wie der iPod und trotzdem scheinen die Leute damit nicht so überfordert zu sein. Also das ist schon...
Aber jetzt müssen wir auch nochmal was ganz anderes sehen. Das ist kein freier Markt. Von diesem Gedanken muss man sich einfach trennen. Apple hat zugehört, alle haben gesagt, wir wollen Anwendungen entwickeln für dieses Gerät. Das ist Apples Produkt und Apple erlaubt, anderen Anwendern auf dieses Produkt draufzukommen. Und man kann auch wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen, dass die Anzahl der abgelehnten Applikationen im Verhältnis zu der angenommenen Applikation sehr gering ist, die liegt im Promille-Bereich. Es gibt jetzt 3.000-4.000 Applikationen, glaube ich, in diesem Store. Was weiß ich, es sind viele. Und die Zahl der abgelehnten ist wahrscheinlich sehr niedrig. Und vor allem kann man das wahrscheinlich sicher sagen, weil bisher jeder Einzelne auf eine Art und Weise diskutiert wurde, dass es schon gar nicht mehr ging. Und Apple hat verschiedene Verpflichtungen. Erstens ist es eine Aktiengesellschaft und die haben einfach Gewinn zu machen. Und wenn die jetzt Applikationen in ihren Store zulassen würden, die ihr Produkt verschlechtern, in der Gesamtwahrnehmung der Kunden und ich sag dir, die Leute peilen das nicht mit diesem Podcaster. Du peilst das, weil du weißt, wie das funktioniert. Aber ich war ja auch schon als jemand, der eigentlich weiß, was da abgeht, komplett verwirrt von dieser Applikation. Weil ich wusste nicht, in welchem Store der sucht. Der sucht da nicht im iPod. Aber du weißt, ob du das gekauft hast. Ja, ich weiß, dass ich es gekauft habe, aber da weiß ich noch nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Da musst du ja nicht wissen, aber du weißt, dass es scheiße ist und dass du es löschen kannst, weil es nicht von Apple ist. Darum geht es doch.
Ja, aber dann habe ich eine schlechte Experience gehabt. Aber die hast du doch bei vielen, und darum auch.
Darum geht es doch nicht.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn ich im iTunes komme...
Sag mal ein Beispiel, was Apple zugelassen hat, was auf die gleiche Art und Weise verwirrend ist. Wo es wirklich um die Kernfunktionalität dieses Gerätes geht. Da würde mir jetzt so nichts einfallen.
Also ich habe ungefähr 80.000 Taschenlampen-Programme gesehen. Ich habe Feuerzeugprogramme. Ich habe sogar mehr Feuerzeugprogramme gebraucht.
Ja, aber die sind doch schön.
Ja, aber auch die sind extrem verwirrend, weil ich kann mir nicht wirklich eine Kippel damit anmachen. Ach komm, Max.
Also ich meine, es ist nicht so, dass iTunes eine Standard-Feuerzeugfunktion hätte, und dass du die dann damit verwirrst. Das ist wirklich eine ganz andere Anleitung. Hier geht es um die Kerngeschichte von diesem iTunes-Store.
Also es ist doch einfach mal so, dieses Podcasting, dieses Programm bietet mir eine Funktion, die Apple mir nicht gewillt und auch nicht in der Lage ist, zu bieten. Der Entwickler dieses Programms hat es dann nach so gut wie es auf der Plattform irgendwie möglich ist, das implementiert. Er kann nicht auf die Podcast-Datenbank zugreifen, die das iPhone hat, weil dafür ist er Sandbox. Er kann den Podcast nicht rüberspielen in die iPod-Applikation, weil da hat er keinen Zugriff drauf. Das ist keine Möglichkeit. Er hat die einzige Möglichkeit gewählt, die vorhanden ist, um einen Podcast oder sie runterzuladen. Und er hätte dafür vielleicht fünf Euro verlangt. Was eigentlich schade ist, weil das eine Funktionalität ist, die Apple bieten sollte. Aber mir wäre es vielleicht diese fünf Euro oder zehn Euro wert gewesen.
Klar, aber für Apple ist es einfach, Apple will aber diese Funktionalität nicht in eine andere Applikation ausliedern, sondern sie verstehen das als einen Kernfeature ihrer Plattform, was sie sich eben nicht von anderen Anwendern wegnehmen lassen wollen. Sie wollen das selber gestalten. Sie wollen selber definieren, wie Podcast da draufkommt. Das können wir jetzt scheiße finden. Ja, dann sollen sie es hinschreiben. Ich sag dir, ich find das auch scheiße. Ja, wir finden das scheiße. Sie haben das aber hingeschrieben.
Wo denn?
Dieser iTunes Store, da steht drin, dass du eben keine Distributionsmethoden, die Apple selber bietet, für dieses Gerät duplizieren darfst. Du darfst dich nicht über diese Distributionsmethoden hinwegsetzen. Weder über die Distributionsmethoden von Programmen als solchen, noch über die Distributionsmethoden, die du dort hast, und das ist Podcast abonnieren, das ist Musik kaufen und so weiter.
Aber Podcasts werden im Augenblick doch gar nicht distributiert außer über iTunes.
Na ja, es geht ja um iTunes. Es geht um die Funktionalität, es geht um diese iTunes Experience.
Ja, aber im Moment, im Augenblick habe ich doch gar keine Möglichkeiten, über das iPhone direkt einen Podcast runterzuladen.
Ja, natürlich, aber es geht nicht darum, dass wenn irgendein Feature, ich meine, kann doch sein, dass Apple dieses Feature noch einbaut. Bloß Apple will sich das jetzt nicht aus der Hand nehmen lassen von irgendeinem anderen Anbieter und scheißt drauf, dass es dieses Feature jetzt noch nicht gibt. Aber sie erlauben es jetzt auch, dass man das Feature in der Hand auch nicht anderen Leuten in diese Funktionalität wegzunehmen.
Man muss doch einfach mal sagen, dass das für Entwickler, die fürs iPhone entwickeln wollten, dass für die es jetzt einfach, es gibt da diese unbekannte, variable Apple drinnen und die entscheidet darüber, ob ich, also ich kann erstmal anfangen, Programme zu entwickeln. Wie gesagt, ob man vorher mit Apple darüber diskutieren kann oder nicht. Aber ich meine, bei so einer Software hätte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht mal vermutet, dass da Apple möglicherweise was dagegen haben könnte. Also ich entwickle eine Applikation, stelle die beim App Store rein und ich habe nicht nur die Variablen, wie vorher, dass ich nicht weiß, wie lange wird es ungefähr dauern, bis das drin ist, dass ich nicht weiß, wie lange wird es dauern, bis ich irgendwelche Updates rein spielen kann, sondern es besteht einfach noch die Chance, dass meine Investition, die ich getätigt habe, komplett für'n Arsch ist, weil Apple sagt, ähm, nö. Und ohne Begründung.
Nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht so, dass sie keine Begründung gegeben haben.
Sie haben eine extrem schwammige Begründung abgegeben. Sie haben irgendeine Begründung angegeben, die ist eine beliebige Begründung.
Ich finde, dass sie eine sehr stichhaltige Begründung abgegeben haben. Und nachdem ich dieses Programm benutzt habe, kann ich nur sagen, ich kann das voll und ganz unterschreiben. Das wäre nicht gut für diese Plattform. Und zwar, verstehe mich nicht falsch, ich will das jetzt nicht so schönreden, ich will nur sagen, macht euch klar, was diese Plattform ist. Diese Plattform ist kein Personal-Computer.
Podcast-Features vom iPhone wären alle noch scheiße. Da muss man noch auch zulassen, dass da Konkurrenzprodukte... Ne, man muss es nicht zulassen, aber... Dann ist doch für dich eigentlich von Vorteil, wenn da ein Konkurrenzprodukt ist. Vielleicht ist es jetzt noch nicht gut, aber nach einem Jahr wäre es vielleicht voll super. Aber es wird alles im Keim erstickt. Und du, nämlich du, ich benutze gar keinen Podcast, mir ist es egal, aber du musst jetzt ewig auf die Apple-Hinies warten, bis die ihre Features erstmal auf die Reihe kriegen. Eigentlich ist es ja fast nur dein Problem und du verteidigst die auch noch. Ich kann dir nicht so richtig nachvollziehen.
Ich verteidige sie nicht. Ihr versteht mich noch nicht. Das Konkurrenzprodukt sind nicht mögliche Applikationen. Denn kein einziges Programm auf dem iPhone, was Apple zulässt, wird ein Konkurrenzprodukt sein. Sondern Apple erlaubt nur Applikationen, die die Funktionalität erweitern, auf eine Art und Weise, woran Apple selbst keine Interesse hat, das zu tun. Nicht mehr, nicht weniger. Das sagen sie auch ganz klar und offen. Es handelt sich hierbei nicht um einen offenen Personalkomputer. Es handelt sich hier um einen von Apple geöffneten Markt, bei dem Apple dir erlaubt, an dem Produkt iPhone und iPod teilzunehmen. Du bist aber dann Teil dieses Produktes. Es ist nicht eine unkontrollierte Plattform, sondern es ist eine kontrollierte Plattform. Genauso wie die Nintendo Wii eine kontrollierte Plattform ist, wie die Xbox eine kontrollierte Plattform ist, wie die Playstation eine kontrollierte Plattform ist. So ist das iPhone, die iPod-Plattform ist eine kontrollierte Plattform. Darüber machen sie auch überhaupt gar keinen... Da gibt es überhaupt gar keine Frage, dass das so ist. Das muss man einfach klar sehen. Man kann nicht mit derselben Herangehensweise da rangehen. Apple hat hier ein Produkt und sie haben überhaupt gar kein Interesse daran, dass irgendein Developer ihnen das irgendwie verwässert. Und ich sag dir, im Zweifel entscheiden die einfach auch dagegen. Und das ist hier wahrscheinlich auch passiert. Auch bei diesem Mail Wrangler, was ich noch für so ein bisschen diskussionswürdiger gehalten habe. Aber die setzen sich dahin und sagen, okay, wie kommt das bei dem Anwender an? Da gibt es jetzt eine zweite Mail-Applikation, die mehrere Google-Accounts verwaltet. Das mag zwar auf Google beschränkt sein, aber das ist dann sozusagen ein zweiter Mail-Button. Und sie wollen keinen zweiten Mail-Button haben. Das ist einfach so. Und das ist auch relativ leicht nachzuvollziehen, weil Apple will mit diesem Produkt Geld verdienen. Und die verdienen dann Geld, wenn das User-Interface klar ist. Guck dir ihre Werbespots an. Die stellen einfach die Funktionalität vor.
Aber sie verdienen mehr Geld, wenn man die Möglichkeit schafft, also im Augenblick ist es so, dieses Programm Mail Wrangler bietet ja eine Funktionalität, die Apples Programm nicht bietet. Doch! Nein, ich meine...
Es bietet eine Funktionalität, die Apples Programm bietet.
Nee, also Apple bietet keine Suche in Mails zum Beispiel. Dieses Mail Wrangler bietet es. Oder hätte es geboten. Über mehrere Mail-Makers.
Ja, aber über Details, das ist aber ein Foto-Passer. Natürlich gibt es da ein Feature, was nicht drin ist, aber die Grundfunktionalität...
Und ich frag mich, inwiefern es für den Benutzer verwirrend sein soll, wenn er die Möglichkeit hat, sich eine Funktion, die er vorher nie hatte, dazu zu installieren. Also es ist, ich weiß, ich meine, es mag sein, dass das aus Apples Perspektive alles ganz in sich schlüssig ist, aber sorry, das ist...
Apple will sich dieses Mail-Ding nicht außer Hand nehmen lassen. Das musst du einfach akzeptieren. Das ist so. Nennen sie Evil, ja, nennen sie Evil. Ihr Interesse ist einfach, sie wollen sich ihre Plattform auf keinen Fall verwässern lassen. Und wenn sie jetzt irgendeine Mail-Applikation akzeptieren, dann haben sie morgen... Ja, dann ist es denen doch scheißegal. Offensichtlich. Das ist doch deine Entscheidung, ob du an diesem Markt teilnehmen willst.
Moment mal, wenn ich...
Du bist nicht gezwungen, iPhone-Applikationen zu hacken.
Entschuldigung, bitte. Natürlich bin ich nicht gezwungen, iPhone-Applikationen zu hacken. Und man wird sicherlich auch sehen, wie es dann passiert, dass hoffentlich sich iPhone-Entwickler aufgrund dessen zurückziehen. Aber wenn ich mich entschließe dazu, ok, ich investiere jetzt in eine bestimmte Plattform und dann werde ich von dieser Plattform aus wirklich fadenscheinigen Gründen nicht genommen, sondern dann rennt Apple jemand im schlimmsten Fall in die Pleite. Im besten Fall hat er da eine Woche dran gesessen und denkt sich, Mist, habe ich Arbeit investiert für nix. Aber das ist...
Also wenn dich das in die Pleite rennt, dann stimmt einfach dein Business-Modell nicht. Man muss schon einfach auch realistisch sehen, was das ist. Und ich sag dir nochmal, es ist kein Personalkomputer, auf dem du installieren kannst, was du willst. Das iPhone ist ein geschlossenes Produkt.
Und das ist scheiße.
Mit einem geöffneten Plattform für Anwendung. Insofern, jetzt haben wir wieder unsere alten offenen und geschlossen Diskussionen wieder auf den Tisch. Kannst du jetzt geschlossen nennen? Ich sag nach wie vor, sie haben einen Markt überhaupt erst mal erzeugt. Sie erlauben dir, an dem iPhone-Erfolg teilzuhaben. Jetzt kannst du natürlich hergehen und sagen, ach, ohne unsere Applikation würde doch kein Mensch so ein scheiß iPhone kaufen. Das sieht Apple unter Garantie anders. Außerdem ist es so, viele iPhone-Entwickler verdienen sich da gerade eine goldene Nase. Irgendwie dieses Trizm hat 250.000 Dollar eingespielt. In zwei Monaten. Das zeigt, dass man dort zu Apples Bedingungen sehr wohl Geld verdienen kann. Wenn du aber jetzt in einen Bereich gehst, was eben das Verständnis von Apple als die Kernfunktionalität dieses Gerätes ansieht, und das sind einfach die Icons, die da schon da waren, bevor Applikationen installieren konntest, die 1.0 Software, da gab es schon Mail. Und ich sag dir, so verkaufen die dieses Gerät. Die verkaufen den Leuten, die keine Ahnung haben, das ist wirklich für End-User, die verstehen nichts von Podcasts, und wo das irgendwie runtergeladen wird, das peilen die nicht. Das sollen die auch gar nicht peilen. Die kaufen dieses Gerät und da steht drauf, du hast auch Mail. Hier ist ein Mail-Knopf. Und noch ein Mail-Knopf will Apple nicht, weil das natürlich für sie auch eine wichtige Kontrolle darüber ist, welche Dienste sie wie sehr unterstützen. Und jetzt das letzte von mir zu dem Thema, ich hab wirklich lange lange darüber nachgedacht, mit dieser Konkurrenz. Es gibt natürlich Konkurrenz. Aber diese Konkurrenz ist nicht innerhalb der Plattform, sondern, schöne Überleitung zu einem möglichen nächsten Thema, die Konkurrenz ist so etwas wie das Google-Phone. Da kannst du auch Anwendungen installieren und wenn auf diesem Google-Phone eine Podcast-Applikation kommt und du kannst dir auf diesem Teil die Podcasts herunterladen und die Leute sagen Hurra, endlich das Telefon, mit dem man endlich seine Podcasts und The Go runterladen kann, dann hat Apple eine Konkurrenz und wenn sie der Meinung sind, dass sie da an dieses Feature matchen müssen, dann werden sie das auch einbauen. Amen.
Ich bin auch anderer Meinung. Apple mag das ja sehen, wie sie wollen. Ich bin nicht Apple und für mich als Entwickler ist es doof, weil ich im Zweifelsfall gegen eine Wand entwickle und für mich als Anwender ist es doof, weil mir Möglichkeiten genommen werden. Das sind beides. Für jeden außer Apple sind diese Entscheidungen einfach scheiße.
Dir ist aber nichts versprochen worden. Es ist nicht so, dass du das iPhone gekauft hast, dass das da drauf stand und mit diesem Gerät kannst du auch Podcasts und The Go runterladen. Sondern das stand da nicht drauf.
Aber ich finde, sie könnten so ehrlich sein und einfach hinschreiben, dass sie Konkurrenzprodukte nicht dulden werden. Das ist ein klares Statement. Das ist ja am Ende auch so, wie sie es jetzt durchziehen. Dann sollen sie es auch richtig offiziell hinschreiben, dann wissen alle Bescheid und dann fangen sie auch gar nicht erst an.
Wo denn? Das haben sie relativ deutlich gesagt. Steve Jobs hat das auf der Keynote irgendwie gesagt. We won't accept everything. Und da steht irgendwie Unforeseen und alles, was irgendwie...
Das ist keine Aussage.
Ja, doch, das ist die klare Aussage, dass dir nicht alles geht. Na klar ist das, was in dem SDK-Vertrag, den du alles bekommst.
Das ist so, als wenn du ein Gesetz machst, du kannst für folgende Sachen verhaftet werden und aber auch noch für alle anderen Sachen, die uns eventuell einfallen könnten. Da weißt du doch nie, ob du nun was Illegales machst oder nicht. So kann man das nicht machen, da ist gar nichts dran klar.
Gut, ich hab ja auch gesagt, was schlecht gelaufen ist, ist doch ganz klar, ihre Art und Weise das zu kompletten.
Konkurrenzprodukte ist doch nicht anverschieden. Konkurrenzprodukte sind Konkurrenzprodukte. Das könnten sie direkt so hinschreiben, damit alle Leute das auch genau wissen. Und dann ist es zumindest schon mal ehrlich. Aber bisher ist es so, ja, das Konkurrenz, die putzt man mal weg, aber so richtig sagen wollen wir es nicht, weil es macht ja Bad Karma. Aber Bad Karma, finde ich, haben sie jetzt eh schon.
Ich glaube, ihr habt ein falsches Verständnis von dieser Plattform. Ich finde den Begriff Konkurrenzprodukte, das ist einfach eine Plattform, die bei Design keine Konkurrenz hat. Deswegen ist sie geschlossen. Deswegen ist da ein NDA drauf. Deswegen ist es Apple, die die Applikation prüfen muss. Man kann auch nicht ernsthaft davon ausgehen, dass Apple irgendeine Applikation dort veröffentlicht wird, die ihnen selbst Konkurrenz macht. Das glaubt ihr doch nicht im Traum.
Ich glaube, weil dafür kriegen die 30%.
Das ist doch naiv. 30%, das ist nix.
Das ist eine ganze Menge für nix tun.
Kostkassa kostet 5 Dollar oder 10 Dollar, 11.000 mal verkauft. 1000 Dollar, weißt du, dafür riskieren die eine Verweichung ihres User-Interfaces in der Wahrnehmung ihres Produktes. Ach Tim, das ist dem Scheiß egal.
Auf meinem iPhone hat sich nix verweicht. Außer bei den 1000 Leuten, die es vielleicht haben wollten, aber das ist doch dann deren Ding. Ich weiß nicht, ich finde da nichts verbessert.
Da hat sich nichts verweicht, weil diese Applikation ist gar nicht bis auf dein Gerät schaffen. Apple ist einfach extrem protektiv, was diese Plattform betrifft. Das müssen wir einfach akzeptieren. Das wird auch noch eine ganze Weile lang so bleiben.
Wir können darüber unseren Unmut äußern, was ich hiermit getan habe. Und natürlich gibt es die Konkurrenz zum App Store. Und ich weiß nicht, wie das auf deinem Telefon aussieht. Bei mir ist das Icon dazu direkt unter dem App Store-Icon auf dem iPhone. Das heißt Züdia. Und da habe ich alle Applikationen, die ich gerne haben möchte. Und viele Applikationen, die mit dem offiziellen Apple-Modell nicht möglich sind. Vielleicht wird ja da über kurz oder lang auch dieses Podcasting-Programm auftauchen. Und ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, wenn es da auftaucht, dass es nicht mal die Nachteile hat von der App Store-Version, weil es machen kann, was es will. Und damit hat natürlich Apple doch auch direkt auf dem Gerät Konkurrenz. Nämlich, es hat sich ja schon rumgesprochen, wenn ich einen Unlock mache, wenn ich einen Jailbreak mache, kann ich beliebige Software installieren und nicht nur die von Apple zugelassene. Und damit hat Apple Konkurrenz per se. Nicht nur im anderen Gerät.
Ich sehe das nicht so. Ich kann das nachvollziehen. Zusammengefasst, ich verstehe, was sie da tun. Ich finde das vielleicht nicht uneingeschränkt gut, aber ich kann das nachvollziehen. Ich kann nachvollziehen, warum sie das so machen. Ganz klar ist, auf jeden Fall sie kommunizieren derzeit den Entwicklern nicht genug, was sie meinen. Und ich glaube, der Grund dafür ist einfach, dass sie es nicht wissen. Das ist wirklich genau dieses Anvorziehen. Sie wissen nicht genau, was alles darauf zu kommt. Sie schauen sich das an und sie grübeln dann, könnte das eine Verbesserung unseres Produktes sein? Könnte das eine Anwendung sein, dass wenn die irgendwie populär wird und viel gekauft wird und installiert wird, die uns zum Nachteil gereicht, die uns die Kontrolle darüber entzieht, wie wir dieses Produkt weiterentwickeln und was wirklich die zentrale Wahrnehmung ist. Denn wenn sie einmal so eine Applikation akzeptieren, dann das nachträglich zu entziehen, ist viel schwieriger. Deswegen sind sie da auch sehr zurückhaltend. Und derzeit haben sie auch einfach keinen Anlass, jetzt da im Zweifel für den Developer zu reden, weil sie einfach genug Alternativen haben. Die Leute wollen Games, die Leute wollen irgendwie Productivity-Apps, die Leute wollen irgendwie lustigen Kleinscheiß, den sie irgendwie funny finden, da diese Feuerzeuge sind das beste Beispiel. Und meinetwegen auch die Flashlights, die alle nichts taugen, weil sie nicht die Helligkeit wirklich einstellen können. So what? Das ist einfach das, was diese Plattform jetzt ist. Und ich denke, sie setzen auch einfach viel mehr auf Games, Casual Games und eben auf eine gewisse Batterie von Productivity-Apps und das funktioniert ja auch soweit ganz gut.
Naja, gucken wir mal, was da weiterkommt.
Was ist mit dem Google-Phone, Max? Willst du ein Google-Phone haben? Das ist ganz toll, da kann man alles drauf installieren, was man will.
Ja, ich glaube, ich will schon ein Google-Phone haben. Also ich finde, sagen wir so, fangen wir erst mal an, ich habe mir diese Präsentation angeguckt, diese Pressekonferenz von Team Mobile in New York. Und ich meine, ich schaffe es wirklich, ein Telefon so zu präsentieren, dass man es nicht haben möchte danach.
Was kann denn das? Hast du diese Präsentation gesehen?
Ich habe diese Präsentation gesehen. Also es sind ja wirklich furcht, also erst mal sieht dieses Telefon ja wirklich grauenerregend aus. Und grauenerregend trifft es glaube ich relativ gut. Das ist wirklich haarssträubend, also das sieht plastikmäßig aus und es ist so ein komplett veraltetes Modell schlicht und ergreifend, also zumindest was das Gehäuse angeht. Technisch ist es ja wohl auf der Höhe der Zeit, aber es sieht ja erstmal, also machen wir es kurz, es sieht scheiße aus. Es sieht auf den Pressefotos schon falsch aus. Also das ist, was nämlich da ausfällt, auf den offiziellen T-Mobile Pressefotos hängt das Display so ein bisschen schief runter, was wirklich für ein Pressefoto kein guter Zustand ist.
Wie das hängt schief runter?
Nein, wenn man sich das auf dem Pressefotos mal so anguckt, das ist so, das Display ist so ein ganz bisschen schief. Also vermutlich, das hat ja diesen Schiebemechanismus, mit dem man die Tastatur freigeben kann. Und auf diesen Fotos ist eben die Tastatur geöffnet und dann hängt das Display so ein bisschen schief oben dran. Also es ist nicht so richtig schön gerade hochgeschoben, sondern so meh, deutsch schief. Und das eben auf einem offiziellen Pressefoto, wo sowas um Himmels willen nicht passieren darf. Und dann ist Findigenbeobachtern aufgefallen, dass man hat ja direkt auf dem Startdisplay, zumindest auch wiederum auf den Pressebildern, ist ja noch eine Analog-Uhr drauf. Und man hat oben, genauso wie beim iPhone, in der Menüleiste auch noch mal eine Uhr. Und diese beiden Uhren zeigen wiederum auch auf den Pressefotos unterschiedliche Uhrzeiten an. Das ist natürlich kein Problem, was auch auf dem Gerät tatsächlich auftritt, sondern es muss irgendein Photoshop-Problem sein. Aber das ist im Augenblick einer der Hauptvorwürfe, der in der Blogosphäre auftaucht, den auch ich machen würde. Mangelnde Liebe zum Detail.
Du, das ist der Nokia-Standard. Mein Nokia E61, das hat mir auch in unterschiedlichen Applikationen unterschiedliche Uhrzeiten angezeigt.
Ja, aber das macht dieses Telefon nicht. Also das ist tatsächlich, das muss beim Photoshoppen passiert sein.
Also hier auf dem Foto, was in der Wikipedia ist, meinst du dieses 3 Uhr 3?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, welches ich meine.
Die analoge Uhr, die zeigt so 3 Uhr 3,5 an, würde ich sagen.
Ne, ne, das eine ist, die eine Uhr zeigt 9 Uhr 42 an, und die andere zeigt 12 Uhr 13 an.
Echt? Oh Mann!
Weit daneben Zeiten.
Naja, das ist ein Screenshot von irgendwie, da muss man nicht drüber diskutieren.
Ja, aber das darf nicht passieren bei so einem Produkt. Also sorry, das ist nicht gut, wenn so was ist. Ansonsten finde ich ja diese Plattform durchaus ganz interessant. Also ich meine, es kann, also erstmal weiß ich nicht, was das iPhone kann. Es kann kein...
Was kann es denn überhaupt?
Es kann kein Multitouch. Es ist eine Smartphone-Plattform auf Linux-Basis, die jetzt demnächst wahrscheinlich mit ein bisschen Glück auch mal komplett veröffentlicht wird. Also eigentlich nach dem Release des Geräts sollte der gesamte Kernel auch freigegeben werden als Open-Source-Betriebssystem. Und für diese Plattform kann man in Java entwickeln als Endanwender. Das Gerät selber kann das, was man erwartet. Also man hat die übliche Telefonie-Applikation drinne. Es werden sämtliche Daten, die man hat, Kontakte und so weiter über Gmail, über die Luft synchronisiert. Was ich eigentlich eine sehr hübsche Funktion finde, wo man natürlich auch sagen kann, Moment mal, also man braucht, um das Telefon zu benutzen, zwingend einen Gmail-Account. Man kann sich nicht dagegen wehren. Und was natürlich auch jetzt Bedenken wecken könnte, wie ich mir gut vorstellen kann.
Wirklich!
Es könnte, ja, ich weiß nicht, es soll da Leute geben, die da nicht so erfreut drüber sind.
Da wirkt das iPhone auf einmal wie der Garten Eden der Freiheit, ne?
Also darüber läuft diese Synchronisation ab. Die haben so ein App-Store-artiges System dahinter, was wirklich unglaublich scheiße aussieht, wo man eben Applikationen runterladen kann. Da dann wirklich beliebige. Da treten auch schon so die ersten Kritiken auf, so nach dem Motto, was sind denn da für scheiß Applikationen drin? Klar.
Was denn?
Ich weiß nicht, ich konnte leider nicht...
Alle, die bei Apple nicht zugelassen wurden?
Im erster Linie glaube ich mal so Demo-Applikation. Wobei so was ja auch bei Apple passiert.
Was meinst du damit?
Demo, so was technisch möglich ist. Guck mal hier, da fliegt ein Ball rum. Weil habe ich rasch in OpenGL programmiert. So was halt. Also technische, quasi kompilierter Beispielcode. Wobei, das hat man ja auch bei Apple gesehen. Das gab es ja auch schon im App Store, dass Beispielcode von Apple einfach kompiliert worden ist, als Programm beim App Store eingerichtet, eingereicht worden ist und durchgekommen ist. Ja, und...
Warum auch nicht? Ich meine, wenn das ein Beispiel ist für eine Applikation, warum sollte dann so eine Applikation nicht auch angenommen werden? Ich meine, sie werden sicherlich keinen Beispielcode für eine Anwendung liefern, den sie dann nicht akzeptieren würden.
Ja, aber Moment mal, wenn ich jetzt ein Beispielcode-Programm einfach nehme und verkaufe...
Naja, warum? Ich meine, da ist doch dein freier Markt wieder. Ich meine, du kannst halt schon, solange du halt...
Tim, machen wir das kurz. Die beim App Store haben keinen blassen Schimmer. Die sitzen da, ich glaube, da sitzen in Wirklichkeit drei Appchen und die machen mal... Und je nachdem ist ein Programm drinne oder nicht drinne. Also das ist im Augenblick noch das, was am ehesten... Nein, nein, es sind zwei Affen, weil einer hat ja in seiner Mail noch das NDA-Disclosure unten drunter und der andere nicht. Also zwei sind es auf jeden Fall. Also ich glaube nicht, also das ist... Beispielcode darf nicht durchrutschen und im App Store verkauft werden, besonders wenn es Beispielcode ist, der eben genau zum Beispiel in dem Fall ging es, glaube ich, um den Accelerator, also um den Beschleunigungs-Sensor. Das war also notdürftig als Spiel getarnt. Ich habe den Beispielcode auch hier auch mal ausprobiert, funktioniert auch. Aber das als Spiel zu verkaufen, das ist grenzwertig.
Gehen wir noch einmal zurück zu diesen Telefonen. Also es gibt einen Hardware-Feature, das finde ich interessant, was ich auch gerne im iPhone hätte. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut es funktioniert, aber es gibt dort einen, genau, es gibt einen digitalen Kompass. Das ist natürlich sehr interessant, weil du damit eben immer weißt, wohin das Telefon gerade guckt. Und das kann das iPhone derzeit nicht. Und das haben sie natürlich eingebaut wegen Google Street View.
Das haben sie in der Pressekonferenz kurz angezeigt, wie das gehen könnte, dass man quasi, also ja, du wirst in der Lage sein, dein Telefon direkt einfach auf der Straße zu halten, wirst in Street View genau die gleiche Ansicht sehen, die du auch gerade live vor dir siehst. Das ist natürlich kompletter Bullshit, muss man mal sagen, so als Funktion, finde ich zumindest. Wenn man diese Sicht noch mit weiteren Informationen anreichern kann, dann wird es natürlich spannend. So Augmented Reality mäßig.
Ja, haben Sie das nicht sogar als Feature gezeigt, dass man mit der Kamera auf die Gegend zeigt, aber es ist wahrscheinlich nur dieser Kompass plus GPS, mehr ist das nicht.
Im Augenblick ist es noch nicht mehr, plus ein bisschen Street View, aber was eingebettete Informationen war da definitiv noch nicht drin. Und das wurde auch nur so ganz, ganz kurz, fünf Sekunden lang gezeigt oder so was in einem Demo-Video. Ich glaube, da sind sie noch nicht ganz so weit, wie sie sein wollen. Sie haben ja noch ein bisschen Zeit, bis das Telefon tatsächlich ausgeliefert wird, aber ich glaube, das wird so ein Feature sein, was nicht von Anfang an wirklich gut funktionieren wird, wenn es überhaupt da sein wird.
Was heißt du denn von dem Telefon denn das?
Ich hab's so nicht so genau angeguckt, aber ich weiß nicht, so doll anders wird es ja nicht sein. Am Ende kannst du halt telefonieren und dein Zeug damit machen. Dann muss man ja erstmal abwarten, bis die ganzen Programme kommen. Aber ein Vorteil finde ich ist schon, dass ich finde schon, dass es da ein bisschen freier ist von dem, was die Leute da in Programmen drauf machen können. Ich denke schon, dass es ein Vorteil ist. Der Apple-Vorteil ist auch ein Nachteil. Die räumen natürlich mehr auf bei Apple. Es hat aber auch einen Nachteil, dass sie auch Sachen wegräumen, die ich nicht okay finde. Aber da muss man halt sehen, wo man da Kompromisse schließt.
Also es gibt schon jetzt ein paar hübsche Applikationen fürs Google-Phone, die für das iPhone einfach auf Grund nicht möglich sein werden. Also was ich zum Beispiel ganz nett finde, ist, es gibt eine To-Do-Liste quasi, oder eine Erinnerungsfunktion, die einen erinnert, sobald man an einem bestimmten Ort ist. Also zum Beispiel, dass man sagen kann, dass man......in die U-Bahn steigt und an einer bestimmten Stelle geweckt werden will. Die Applikationen gibt es doch schon. Das gibt es zwar auch für iPhone, aber das funktioniert nur, solange man das Programm natürlich nicht beendet.
Okay, das ist ja wieder......auf einem iPhone.
Dieses Feature gibt es aber in OmniFocus.
Ja, aber nur solange man OmniFocus nicht beendet. Und beim Google-Phone läuft die Applikation die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund mit.
Ach so, das ist sozusagen, ich bin jetzt hier und daraufhin wird irgendwas getriggert.
Genau, ich gehe am Laden vorbei und daraufhin kriege ich eine Erinnerung dran, dass ich doch noch...
Das fehlt in der Tat, aber das wäre natürlich die Frage, ob das nicht dann auch mit dieser Push-Notification quasi auch kommt.
Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt drauf, weil diese Push-Not... Also ich meine, davon muss man ja auch noch ständig die Location ermitteln. Und das saugt natürlich ganz gut am Akku. Und außerdem, dann hätte man wirklich den Zustand, dass Apple ständig darüber informiert wird, wo halte ich mich gerade auf. Und das will ich auch gerne nochmal wissen.
Also da würde ich vorher gerne nochmal fragen, ob ich das gut finde. Sagen wir das lieber Google.
Bei Google bleibt das ja im Gerät.
Was sind denn deine Kritikpunkte? Ich hab ja auch noch hier so zwei Sachen, die mir nicht gefallen.
Also eine andere Applikation, die ganz hübsch ist, die hätte wahrscheinlich bei Apple nach aktuellen Stand der Dinge auch keine Chance. Das gab es für gehackte iPhones früher. Das hieß TuneWiki. Das war so ein hübsches Programm, wo man jeden Song in seinem iPod zu einem Karaoke-Song machen konnte, indem einfach der Text dazu eingeblendet wurde, was über ein zentrales Wiki, wo die Lyrics hinterlegt waren, gepflegt wurde. Und das ist so etwas, was jede Wette auf ein iPhone überhaupt keine Chance hätte. Und das ist ein sehr gehyptes Feature auf ein Google-Phone.
Also nicht nur, dass es keine Chance hätte, es geht technisch nicht, weil du einfach keinen Zugriff auf die Musik hast.
Du hast keinen Zugriff auf die Musik, technisch geht es nicht. Und das wäre bestimmt auch so ein Ablehnungsgrund für Apple, so dupliziert iPod-Funktionalitäten und sowas.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und das ist eben auf dem Google-Phone relativ gehyptes Ding. Ansonsten finde ich, was ich erstmal so fern von der Kritik, bevor man dazu kommt, noch ganz interessant finde, ist ein bisschen, also ich hab mich jetzt noch nicht mit der Anwendungsentwicklung fürs Google-Phone wirklich auseinandergesetzt, aber man merkt einen Unterschied an der Firmenphilosophie zwischen, finde ich zumindest, Google und Apple. Und zwar Apple kommt wirklich offensichtlich aus dem Desktop-Bereich und hat einen Desktop-Betriebssystem auf das Telefon übertragen. Und Google, finde ich, vom Gefühl her, ist eine Webfirma und hat Webviews, also sozusagen Web-Applikationsentwicklung auf dem Telefon übertragen. Also es gibt zum Beispiel, was sie sehr weit herausstreichen, ist, wie unglaublich einfach es ist, HTML-Code überall in dein Programm einzublenden und da HTML-Code und hier HTML-Code. Und ich glaube, dass so vom Gefühl her, dass HTML und Web und JavaScript auf dem iPhone doch eher ungeliebte Stiefkinder sind. Also es ist relativ gut drin, klar, aber nicht als zentrales Bedienelement an Applikationen gedacht im Augenblick. Und das scheint mir beim Google-Fond doch viel, viel ausgeprägter zu sein. Also dass man im Endeffekt mit Java nur noch ein bisschen HTML-Code erzeugt und dann seine Applikation mit JavaScript zum Beispiel speuert.
Das, naja, also da hast du sicherlich recht mit deiner Einschätzung, dass das für sie eine große Priorität hat, ist ja ganz klar. Sie pushen da natürlich auch Gears und all die Sachen, die sie jetzt auch mit Chrome machen, das ist ganz klar ihre Development-Environment, auch wenn sie natürlich mit dem Java schon auch die Notwendigkeit sehen für Code, der eben jetzt nicht in JavaScript geschrieben ist.
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Wo man abwarten muss, ob nicht JavaScript nochmal so ein richtiger First Citizen wird mit den letzten Entwicklungen, auch hier bei Safari mit dem neuen Squirrel-Fresh-Extreme. Also diese ganze JavaScript-Beschleunigung, die geht ja gerade los, wie nichts gut ist. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass JavaScript in naher Zukunft anfangen wird, den klassischen Desktop-Programmiersprachen Konkurrenz zu machen. Aber davon mal abgesehen, nochmal bei dem Telefon zu bleiben. Also, ja, du hast recht. Beim iPhone ist es nicht ganz so präsent. Sie featuren natürlich sehr viel mehr Cocoa. Was nachvollziehbar ist. Ich meine, sie haben auch einen Multitouch, das hat dieses Google-Dingsbums nicht. Und dadurch, dass dieses Telefon das nicht hat, also auch technisch nicht kann, können sie es nicht nachgerissen haben.
Nur technisch nicht können, im Augenblick. Also das Betriebssystem kann es wohl prinzipiell, aber dieses konkrete Gerät kann es noch nicht.
Damit ist es tot. Das heißt, dass alle Anwendungen, die jetzt erstmal rauskommen, müssen, also alle Anwendungen in langer Zukunft müssen berücksichtigen, dass ein Telefon das auch nicht kann. Und damit wird es niemand richtig nutzen.
Alle Programme müssen in Zukunft theoretisch damit umgehen können, dass es kein Touchscreen gibt. Weil auch die Möglichkeit theoretisch besteht, Touchscreen-Geräte zu bauen. Und das ist echt mal...
Aber das ist doch ein Touchscreen, oder nicht?
Ja, das ist ein Touchscreen, das funktioniert. Aber das heißt nicht, dass das nächste Google Phone auch ein Touchscreen haben wird. Oder es wird ja weitere Geräte geben, das wird ja nicht das einzige Gerät bleiben.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass es überhaupt noch Telefone gibt, die kein Touchscreen haben.
Ich hoffe mal, dass es wirklich eine Totgeburt ist für Google und dass wirklich so ein Gerät nicht kommen wird. Also ein Smartphone ohne Touchscreen, das wäre ja wirklich albern. Das kennt man ja sonst nur von Google.
Das kommt nicht, das kommt nicht, das kommt nicht.
Aber es ist prinzipiell vorgesehen, dass es notwendig ist. Und auch dieses Google Phone hat ja unten so einen kleinen hässlichen Trackball unten dran, mit dem man es statt des Touchscreens bedienen kann. Ja, da ist das kleine Ding in der Mitte da, das ist so ein kleiner Trackball und über den kann man wohl praktisch jegliche Funktionalitäten auch nutzen.
Aber es gibt keine Software-Tastatur bei dem Teil, oder?
Es gibt keine Software-Tastatur. Sondern du hast nur die Hardware-Tastatur im Augenblick.
Das ist auch bekloppt. Ich muss ja sagen, ich war ja skeptisch, aber diese iPhone-Tastatur, wenn man sich daran erstmal gewöhnt hat, damit bin ich schneller als mit jeder anderen Knopf-Tastatur.
Total, oder? Also ich hab neulich mal, das ist natürlich immer eine Frage der Übung, aber du hattest ja mit deinem Nokia, welches hattest du vorher? Dein Nokia-Telefon?
E61.
E61, was ja eigentlich für ein Smartphone schon eine sehr gute Tastatur hat. Also ich nehme an, die kannst du problemlos mit einem Blackberry aufnehmen, oder? Glücklicher. Und ich glaube, da ist wirklich die iPhone-Tastatur besser. Und ich glaube, sie sind einfach noch nicht so weit. Es wird Soft-Tastaturen geben für das Google-Phone. Vermutlich sogar von Drittherstellern. Also ich hab da neulich so eine sehr schöne Demo-Applikation gesehen, wo man beim Tippen nicht mal mehr die Finger hochgenommen hat von der Tastatur.
Ach, diese Wischi-Waschi.
Genau, das war beim FSK-Lokal, also Video. Genau, das sah doch sehr hübsch aus. Ich nehme an, das wird einfach... Das weiß ich ja nicht. Ja, das Google-Phone ist quasi das neue Windows. Wird nie so schick sein wie Apple und wird niemals so perfekt auf den Punkt sein. Aber es wird unglaublich viel Software dafür geben. Bin ich bereit zu wetten. Und es wird auf sehr, sehr vielen Geräten laufen. Und es wird, sobald das Open Source irgendwo da ist... Ich bin gespannt, wann wir das erste Mal sehen, Google-OS auf dem... also das Google-Phone-OS auf dem iPhone. Es wird bestimmt irgendeinen Hacker geben, der das macht.
Das glaube ich nie und nimmer. Dennis, muss man wieder was sagen, würden jetzt die Hörer sagen?
Telefone sind langweilig. Wobei mir das iPhone ja den Arsch gerettet hat.
Telefone sind die Zukunft.
Na ja, eigentlich schon, aber...
Warum hat es dir den Arsch gerettet?
Das finde ich auch interessant. Na, weil ich bin mit einem Moped von Aachen nach Paderborn gefahren, also mit Motorrad. Und unterwegs war mein Navi, mein TomTom, war leer. Und dann wusste ich nicht weiter. Und es war auch schon langsam dunkel. Dann hab ich halt immer mein iPhone rausgeholt, hab mich ungefähr anzeigen lassen, wo ich bin. Und bin dann immer von einem Ort zum nächsten gedüstet und hab dann immer wieder nachgeguckt. Geht natürlich auf dem Motorrad nicht so prima. Ich musste mal anhalten, Handschuhe aus und den ganzen Scheiß. Aber ich hab mich nach Hause gebracht. Ihr kennt doch die ganzen kleinen Scheißörtchen irgendwie nicht. Da tingelst du dich halt von einem Dorf zum nächsten. Ich wollte ja nicht in eine riesen Großstadt, so wie Berlin, wo du irgendwie schon 500 Kilometer vorher ein Schild hast, wieder nach Hause kommst, sondern so bei so einem kleinen Ort, musste ich halt da durchhangeln.
Gut. Noch ein letztes Wort zu dem G1.
Abwarten.
Hat nur ein Gigabyte RAM. Flash, mein ich.
Nee, das hat sogar weniger.
Aber eingebaut hat es ganz wenig. Also es hat weniger RAM.
Ich glaube, es hat 512 GB Flash oder so was?
Ein Gigabyte.
Ein Gigabyte, ja, tatsächlich.
Ja, es ist ein Micro SD, du kannst halt 8 GB reinstecken, dann zahlst du halt nochmal 40 Dollar mehr. Und dann bist du preislich aber auch so bei dem nominellen Preis vom iPhone und hast noch nicht mal Multitouch. Ich weiß nicht. Also das ist halt, wie ich schon mal sagte, das ist jetzt erstmal für ganz andere Leute. Ich glaube, das ist so für Leute, die vorher irgendwie Windows-Mobile-Telefone und Symbian benutzt haben. Für die mag das einen Appeal haben. Auch die Leute, die aus unerklärlichen Gründen halt eine Tastatur haben wollen. Ich finde das ja total unpraktisch. Zumal man bei dem Ding halt auch, wenn die Tastatur, dann muss man das halt auch immer im Querformat nutzen. Also es gibt keine Tastatur im Hochformat, sondern nur im Querformat. Das ist irgendwie alles so reduziert, alles so festgelegt. Aber gut, das passt dann zu dem Benutzerprofil von den anderen Telefonen. Ich denke, dass vor allem Microsoft ein Problem damit haben wird. Und dass sie gerade richtig rudern, merkt man auch, dass sie jetzt ihre Windows-Mobile-7-Geschichte, die sie eigentlich Anfang nächsten Jahres rausbringen wollten, auf Ende nächsten Jahres verschoben haben. Also man merkt richtig, dass die ein Problem haben.
Also da hab ich neulich erst mal kurz zwischendurch gelesen, gestern erst das erste Mal gelesen, dass Windows-Mobile, der eingebaute Browser, nach wie vor auf dem Internet Explorer haltet euch fest vier basiert. Das hat mich wirklich mal richtig umgehauen. Also dass die Browser-Engine, die in diesen Telefonen, aktuell verkauften Windows-Mobile-Telefonen, aus dem letzten Jahrtausend stammt. Das ist, finde ich ja mal, also...
Das könnte sogar der Grund sein, oder einer der Gründe sein, warum sie das jetzt alles verschieben, weil sie merken, dass sie jetzt mit so ein bisschen Wapp-Browser-Style nicht mehr weiterkommen, sondern dass sie im Prinzip wahrscheinlich auf die Code-Basis von dem IE, was ist jetzt der nächste?
Acht!
Acht! gehen müssen, damit sie da überhaupt noch mithalten können, weil mit WebKit geht's gerade so scheiße ab, und dadurch, dass Google das unterstützt und Apple das unterstützt, sind sie im Headset-Bereich einfach hinten. Und ich glaube, dass... diese ganze Touch-Geschichte, ich meine, jeder gute iPhone-Klon in Anführungsstrichen wie iPhone Killer, wie Spiegel Online das nennen würde, die haben ja jede Woche irgendwie einen anderen auf ihrer Hauptseite, muss dieselbe Optik haben. Da müssen die Icons vorne sein, da muss irgendwie Touch sein. Die Art und Weise, wie man ein iPhone benutzt, ist jetzt einfach so hip, dass sie sich dem nicht mehr entziehen können. Dann haben sie sich ihre Scheiß-Software mit ihrem blöden Startmenü angeschaut und haben festgestellt, das müssen wir jetzt alles umschreiben, weil unsere Kunden, nämlich hier so Buden wie HTC und Sony Ericsson, wer Windows Mobile überhaupt noch einsetzt, die sagen jetzt, wir möchten genau das haben, was Apple auch hat. Bitte! Microsoft. Und da sie hier nicht ein Monopol haben und nicht sagen können, eat the shit we give to you, sondern dass sie dann im Zweifelsfall auch diese Verträge verlieren, weil die jetzt alle auf verschiedene Pferde setzen. Die setzen auf Google, die setzen auf sonstiges Linux. Keine Ahnung, ich schätze mal Nokias Smartphone. Das nächste wird halt ein Linux-Phone sein mit QT. Vorausgesagt, mal gucken.
Wie heißt das denn der Prototyp, der schon bei Batman aufgetaucht ist, kurz für dieses Nokia Touch-Telefon, das jetzt im Oktober kommen wird, vermutlich, 2.3. Oktober, bild ich mir ein.
Nächste Woche wird das kommen. Na, da bin ich ja mal gespannt. Aber mein Tipp ist, es basiert nicht mehr auf Symbian.
Genau, das werden wir sehen.
Apropos WebKit. Habt ihr denn schon gesehen, dass es jetzt eine neue Version von dem Squirrelfish gibt?
Hat sich ja gerade schon erwähnt, aber erzähl mal.
Echt, hast du? Hab ich mir nicht aufgepasst gerade. Na, es gibt halt eine neue Version, die jetzt mal noch schneller ist und den S3-Test irgendwie auch von den Timing-Anforderungen irgendwie schafft darzustellen.
Genau, als erster Browser überhaupt.
Ja, sind die immer noch ganz weit vorne. Es gibt immer noch keinen release-Browser, der S3 kann. Also gar keinen. Auch der Safari, der release, kann das ja auch noch nicht. Müssen wir also weiter abwarten.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es diese Performance-Bedingungen noch gibt, um S3 wirklich komplett abzuschließen. Da gab es ja diesen Wettlauf mit Opera und so.
Was ist denn nun gerade?
Irgendwas Kanadisches auf jeden Fall.
Nee, man kann irgendwie dann über den Text gehen oben und da kommt bei mir wird meine Maus zu so einem Fragezeichen und da kann man dann klicken und dann kommt so ein Menü, so ein kleines und da steht drin, welche Tests fehlgeschlagen sind oder wenn alles geklappt hat, ob es von der Zeit her ok war. Und bei mir steht jetzt weil ich noch doch, ich hab eigentlich den neuesten er sagt hier, da haben wir irgendwie 6 Tests, waren gerade zu langsam, ich klick mal nochmal, wer weiß, was hier schon wieder los ist.
Ja, aber man brauchte auch ein sehr sehr schnelles MacBook Pro bisher, damit die Tests wirklich gut bestanden wären.
So, jetzt hab ich hier 0,87 Sekunden, no JavaScript Errors and no timing issues. Also jetzt hat das geklappt. Neueste Webkit-Version, wenn Leute da Spaß dran haben, kann ich die ja runterladen. Gibt's auch einen Blog-Eintrag von den Jungs zu. Ansonsten hab ich gerade gelesen, ist noch OmniWeb 5.8 rausgekommen, gerade ganz frisch, für Leute, die OmniWeb bevorzugen. Du warst ja auch so ein OmniWeb-Nutzer, oder Tim?
Ja, hab ich mir auch kurz runtergeladen, aber jetzt noch nicht so viel benutzt. Ist halt so, einfach das neueste Web-Kit mit drin. Sie haben einfach da mit Safari 301 oder so nachgezogen. Ansonsten ist OmniWeb immer noch OmniWeb. Spielt halt auf dem Markt keine große Rolle, aber ich finde immer noch, dass es so ein paar Nettigkeiten hat. Trotzdem ist man die Fold-Browser derzeit immer noch Safari.
Tolle Cookieverwaltung, die der OmniWeb hat.
So, haben wir denn noch Themenkarten?
Was gibt's denn noch?
Da gibt's ja knackige Podcast-Länge gerade.
Ja, gab's doch Updates ohne Ende, müssen wir da drüber irgendwas erzählen. Ich meine, iTunes 8 kam irgendwie raus, QuickTime irgendwie Updates, 10.5.5 kam raus.
Ja, gut. Darüber müssen wir aber nicht viel reden, aber über iTunes 8 haben wir schon geredet.
Ich finde den neuen iPod Nano sehr schick. Ich bin am Überlegen, ob ich mir einfach mal den Luxus eines neuen iPod Nanos kaufe, obwohl ich gar keinen brauche.
Hier ist die aktuelle Verschwörungstheorie zur iPod Nano. Es gibt eine Verschwörungstheorie? Ja, das Ding fährt Mac OS X.
Das ist die Verschwörung?
Das ist jetzt mal so eine These. Ich habe da selber nicht drüber nachgedacht. Irgendjemand, mit dem ich mich drüber unterhalten habe, meinte, dass das jetzt doch eigentlich OS X sein müsste, weil es diverse Features da drin gibt, die es vorher nicht gab, die eigentlich nur mit OS X wirklich realisierbar sind.
Also das einzige, was mir dafür einfällt, was da in Frage kommt, wäre, dass es ja jetzt ein Speech-Interface hat, der iPod Nano. Und ich glaube aber nicht, dass das das Gerät nativ macht, sondern Apple hat sich schon... Das macht iTunes, genau. Die haben sich das ja irgendwann mal patentieren lassen, dass iTunes dann die Speech-Sachen macht und dann einfach rüberspielt auf den iPod Nano in dem Moment. Also wenn ich einen Musiker habe, oder einen Album-Namen, dann spricht iTunes quasi das ein mit der Speech-Software und spielt das dann rüber als Sound-Datei auf den iPod Nano, sodass ich es dann per Audio-Ausgabe steuern kann. Also das, aber mehr fällt mir da ehrlich gesagt im Augenblick nicht ein an Features, die jetzt wirklich so toll, die es nur auf Mac OS X gibt.
Na, erstmal Accelerometer-Support mit dem automatischen Drehen des Bildschirms. Das ist definitiv mit den entsprechenden Effekten, die du dafür brauchst. Das riecht für mich schon nach Quarz. Ich hab's jetzt leider noch nicht überprüfen können, aber wenn man so ein Ding in der Hand hat, ich denke, es gibt einen klaren Indikator, weil es gab ja schon auf dem iPod bisher dieses Coverflow, auf dem Nano. Wenn man sich das aber mal genau anschaut, merkt man, dass die Skalierung der Grafiken nicht so antialiast ist, wie man das von Mac gewohnt ist, sondern du hast ja so Jiggy kann. Ich vermute jetzt mal, der Lackenhaus-Test ist, dass das jetzt so aussieht, wie man das gewohnt ist. Und wie gesagt, ich vermute, diese ganze Accelerometer und Drehgeschichte, sie werden da einfach die Software, sie werden da sozusagen eine iPod Touch abgespeckte Version drin haben. Warum nicht? Ich meine, sie müssen auch ihre Preise senken und das wäre eine sehr einfache Methode, ihre Preise zu senken, weil sie dann keine Lizenzgebühren mehr für dieses andere Betriebssystem bezahlen müssen.
Naja, aber ich würde mal sagen, ich wohne es jetzt wirklich nur ein Tipp zur extrem blauen hinein, dass nach wie vor Mac OS X doch ein bisschen aufwändiger ist, was die Prozessorleistung angeht, als dieses speziell für Kleinstgeräte entwickelte Betriebssystem und das beim iPod Nano wahrscheinlich eher die Prozessorleistung das Entscheidende sein wird. Also lieber einen etwas billigeren Prozessor einbauen und dafür mal vielleicht mal auch böse Winken bei den Lizenzverhandlungen.
Aber die wollen noch auch Games ermöglichen, da musst du doch eben ein bisschen Prozessorleistung reinmachen und dann ist es wiederum egal.
Ja, aber die Games, die gibt's doch, die gab's doch schon ewig.
Na, aber aufwändigere Games als vorher.
Also das weiß ich, das weiß ich. Ich hab mich mit Games auf dem iPod wirklich, das hat mich nie interessiert, hab ich mich nie mit beschäftigt. Und das wär natürlich mal eine spannende Frage. Also sagen wir so, das wär ein deutlicher Indikator, wenn die Spiele, die alten Spiele noch funktionieren auf dem neuen iPod, dann hat er wahrscheinlich noch das alte Betriebssystem, oder? Eine Emulation, werden sie da nicht großartig reingespielst?
Na, werden wir ja demnächst sehen, wenn's denn ein Jailbreak gibt, obwohl an die Dinger, die haben ja keine WLAN, keine NIC, kommt man ja nicht rein.
iPod Nano, da gibt's keinen Jailbreak für. iPod Touch werden dann.
Nee, ich mein jetzt Nano. Na noch gibt's keinen, aber vielleicht gibt's ja irgendwann einen. Aber was sollte man dann da mit machen, weil's ja halt kein WLAN hat?
Man könnte Lieblings drauf installieren.
Auf jeden Fall, das User Interface von dem neuen iPod Nano ist komplett neu. Ja, es sieht so ein bisschen aus wie das Alter, aber es ist neu. Und es hat irgendwie Transparenz und es hat irgendwie sich drehende Screens und eine andere Ausrichtung und lalalala. Was ganz schick ist? Und ich schäge wenig Gründe, warum sie da nicht ihr eigenes OS nehmen sollten.
Also, einfach, einfach mal...
Wollen sie nicht alles doppelt entwickeln? Das ist doch viel zu teuer. Warum sollen sie für zwei Betriebssysteme entwickeln? Nur weil sie noch einen weiteren iPod haben.
Ja, zwei weitere iPods.
Ja, der Classic, dem wird es sicherlich...
Mal sehen, wie lange es den noch gibt, klar.
Genau, so. Und die Zukunft liegt definitiv in diesem, kann Video, lalalala, hast nicht gesehen und hat immer noch mehr Features-Dingern und irgendwie Touch.
Aber der Classic hat doch das gleiche OS wie der Nano, welches auch immer das ist, oder nicht? Oder haben die andere Features?
Der neue Nano hat mehr Features als der Classic.
Echt?
Das Interface sieht halt anders aus. Also das Display ist ja jetzt... Um jetzt mal ein bisschen vom ästhetischen Standpunkt heran zu gehen, ich fand den iPod-Nummer der zweiten Generation, den hatte ich und das ist nach wie vor mein liebster iPod. Also gerade was so reine iPod-Funktionalitäten angeht, ist der so unglaublich genügsam, also ich brauchte den wirklich nie explizit zu laden, das Gerät.
Der vorher, der so ein komisches Seitenverhältnis hatte, ja. Der nicht so länglich war, sondern mehr so breit.
Nee, nee, ich hatte den davor. Ich hatte den länglichen, die zweite Generation.
Ich hab gelesen, dass dieses breite ist wohl nicht so richtig angekommen und deswegen sind sie zu dem alten Formfaktor wieder zurückgegangen und ich kann das von meinem Persönlichen, hatte so ein Ding nie, aber ich kann es auch nur bestätigen, dass das einfach viel ansprechender aussieht als so ein flach geklopftes Ding, was wir davor hatten.
Ich finde den auch viel schicker. Dann haben sie im Gegensatz zu diesem iPod Nano vorher, wo sie dieses zweigeteilte Display hatten, dass auf der einen Hälfte des Displays wurden dir die Titel angezeigt, auf der anderen Hälfte des Displays gab es dann Cover-Bilder dazu, was sicherlich erst mal so ganz hübsch ist, aber einfach mal komplett blödsinnig. Das haben sie jetzt einfach gemacht, wir packen das Screen hochkant rein, dadurch passt viel mehr Information aufs Display drauf, ohne dass ich das großartig teilen muss. Und ich finde den neuen iPod Nano, bis auf den Accelerometer, diese Beschleunigungssensor, den mag ich ja persönlich überhaupt nicht so, finde ich das aber ein sehr schönes, ein sehr schönes iPod, den ich durchaus hier gerne im Schrank liegen hätte. Ich brauche ihn nicht, ich werde mir nicht holen, aber ich finde ihn schick.
Mir fällt noch ein Argument ein, warum der iPod Nano OS X fährt und der iPod Classic nicht. Also erstmal, der iPod Classic hat glaube ich noch das alte Interface von dem letzten iPod Classic und auch von dem alten 3G Nano, also mit dieser Aufteilung, wie du es beschrieben hast. Beim Nano ist es anders, aber es gibt jetzt auch noch diese Nike, wie heißt das, iPod plus Nike Feature mit diesem Chip im Schuh, mit dem der iPod kommuniziert. Das ist ja jetzt beim iPod Nano eingebaut und das ist auch beim iPod Touch eingebaut. Die selbe Funktionalität ist sozusagen grundsätzlich schon mal eingebaut, sowohl da und beim iPod Touch gab es auch schon Hinweise, ich glaube, hat irgendeiner auseinandergebaut, dass es jetzt da einen Bluetooth Stein mit drin gibt, sie aber nicht wirklich Bluetooth anbieten, sondern wahrscheinlich das nur benutzen für die Kommunikation.
Womit?
Und wahrscheinlich ist es mit diesem Chip.
Ne, mit dem Chip, das ist, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, exakt das gleiche Verhalten wie bei dem alten iPod.
Wie war das?
Das ist ein eigener Funkstandard. Irgendjemand hat sich mal darüber beschwert, dass die Verschlüsselung, dass die Datenübertragung unverschlüsselt ist. Das ist relativ simpel, das sendet. Also es ist kein standardisiertes Protokoll. Also jedenfalls nicht eins von diesen üblichen. Und die machen das nicht per Bluetooth.
Ne, sie machen es nicht mit dem Bluetooth-Protokoll, aber sie machen es vielleicht mit demselben Stein, mit dem sie auch Bluetooth machen können. Sie fahren nicht den ganzen Stack drauf, sondern sie fahren nur so ein Subset auf so einer niedrigeren Ebene, benutzen nur den Link-Level und nicht den Rest. Damit sparen sich diese ganzen Pairing und diesen ganzen Security-Scheiß.
Also das muss auf jeden Fall, ansonsten geht das ja gar nicht, weil ich meine, wenn du da so ein Ding im Schuh drinnen stecken hast, dann müsstest du jedes Mal ein Pairing machen, wenn sich der Schuh bewegt. Das wär ja komplett albern. Ich glaube, die schicken nur einen Tab für die wesentlichen Schicken, die nur, wenn sie eine Bewegung haben, so beschleunigungsmäßig, tick, tick, tick, schicken sie irgendwie, sendet der hin und wieder mal und das wird dann innen empfangen. Möglicherweise von dem Bluetooth-Ship, das kann natürlich durchaus sein.
Wie auch immer, meine These ist nur die. Jetzt wo sie das alles neu gemacht haben und wo sie diese Funktionalität direkt ins Gerät mit eingebaut haben und das nicht so eine externe Rannbammelgeschichte ist, das heißt ja auch, dass die ganze RF-Kommunikation da drin ist. Das heißt, dass sie auch Software dafür geschrieben haben, die in diesem Betriebssystem mit drin ist. Und ich glaub einfach nicht, dass sie das jetzt, wo sie das gleichzeitig releasen, dass sie da eine Implementierung machen für den Touch und eine Implementierung machen für den Nano. Das ist dieselbe Software-Basis.
Das kann ich relativ leicht aushebeln, dieses Argument, weil die Software war ja schon vorher auf dem iPod drauf und alles, was du da unten dran gesteckt hast war ein bisschen zusätzliche Hardware, die dann über den iPod angesprochen worden ist. Die Hardware ist jetzt einfach mit im Gerät drinnen. Das ist in meinen Augen wirklich kein Indikator dafür.
Das ist aber ein ganz anderes Treibermodell. Kommunizierst du über das Dock? Natürlich. Du hast über das Dock nicht den vollen Prozessorbus. Wenn das im Gerät eingebaut ist, dann liegt das einfach direkt am Prozessor, wenn nicht sogar mit in diesem SoC-Stein. Das wäre auch die Vorbereitung. Es würde insofern Sinn machen, dass es ein Bluetooth-Chip ist, wie ich gelesen habe, weil sie Bluetooth über kurz oder lang einbauen werden müssen. Für Kopfhörer und für sonstige Geschichten, für Integration ins Auto und so weiter.
Also schlecht würde ich es nicht finden, aber ich würde sagen, dass es, also ich glaube, man kriegt das auch hin, indem sie einfach ein virtuelles Dock noch zusätzlich unten einbauen und dann hängt da eben nur diese iPod, dieses Nike Zeug dran und damit würden sie es wahrscheinlich auch hinkriegen.
So, die Wette läuft, Max.
Wir haben noch eine Wette, kann das sein?
Ja, du kriegst noch Club-Mate von mir.
Ich krieg noch Club-Mate. Jetzt, bring mal mit aus Toronto. Gut, die nächste Wette am Laufen. Hat der iPod Nano Mac OS X drauf? Ich sag nein. Ich sage, der hat das gleiche alte Betriebssystem.
So, haben wir noch eine Gesprächsthemen-Karte. Wir haben jetzt eine Stunde 50. Ich denke, wir können langsam mal Schluss machen, oder?
Wir können langsam mal Schluss machen, auf jeden Fall.
Oder, Dennis? Dann machen wir es kurz und schmerzlos, würde ich sagen. Und sagen Tschüss. Achso, ich kann ja noch mal ein bisschen erzählen. Wir sind hier zwar noch arg am Kämpfen, aber auf blinklites.net gibt es irgendwie viele nette Software. Und wir haben auch gerade eine Applikation im iTunes-App Store fürs iPhone. Die Coding Monkeys hier. Du weißt schon, die von SubEtherEdit und die des Circulator machen, sind ja hier mit im Team. Und die haben hier geilen Simulator für unsere Blinkenlites-Installation gehackt. Und die kommt hoffentlich sehr bald im App Store. Sieht richtig schick aus. Da sind wir schon ganz gespannt drauf. Und ich hoffe, es wird auch die nächsten Tage noch weitere nette Software geben für den Mac. Es gibt ein neues Release für dieses Quartz-Komposer-Kram.
Da hab ich mal eine kurze Frage an dich. Und zwar habe ich gesehen auf Screenshots, dass man vor diesem Gebäude, dass da noch ein bisschen Rasen mit eingeblendet war und so war es alles. Das war jetzt aber in der Mac-Applikation nicht der Fall. Ist das dann in der iPhone-Applikation drin? Oder ist das in einer späteren Version? Oder war ich zu dämlich, das Programm richtig zu bedienen?
Also derzeit ist das in der iPhone-Applikation drin. Die noch nicht released ist im Store. Aber ihr könnt uns gerne eure ID's schicken, dann kann ich sie schon mal installieren lassen. Und es ist geplant, das auch noch in die Mac-Applikation einzubauen. Wir sind hier bloß gerade extrem eingebunden mit 1000 Sachen und wir haben wirklich noch richtig, richtig viele Probleme zu lösen. Und ich hoffe, dass das hier überhaupt alles in time funktionieren wird. Aber geplant ist eigentlich auch noch, das für den Mac anzupassen. Die aktuelle Version von diesem Stereoskop-Simulator für den Mac hat so eine Auto-Update-Funktion. Und wenn es da halt dann noch rechtzeitig eine neue Funktion gibt, dann kommt die halt automatisch per Update.
Okay, dann bleibt uns eigentlich nichts weiter zu sagen. Dennis und mir drücken wir euch sämtliche Daumen, oder?
Können wir wirklich gut gebrauchen.
Wir hoffen, dass das Programm nicht wegen limited usability abgelehnt wird.
Oder wegen Dupli-Cache.
Dann wirst du gucken.
Apple plant eigene Blinken-Lights-Informationen.
Dann gibts hoffentlich noch ein Studio-Release.
Dann werd ich gepisst.
Kaum ist er selber von getroffen.
Dann sind sie evil. Dann sagen wir Dankeschön fürs Zuhören. Ich bin hier noch bis vorletzte Woche Oktober. Also bin noch eine Weile da. Ich denke, wir werden hier noch mal eine Ausgabe aus Toronto machen.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Das hat auch Spaß gemacht, muss ich ja mal sagen. Mal sehen, ob es jetzt mit dem Zusammenschneiden klappt.
Ach so, was...
Okay.
Genau, aber das klären wir, nachdem wir Rekordstopp gedrückt haben, oder?
Genau, dann drücken wir jetzt auf Rekordstopp und sagen Tschüss! Tschüss bald!